Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brittlaf.
Und ja, mir ist wahrscheinlich schon erwartet habt jetzt einen etwas schnellerer Folge. Wollen wir noch mal so ein kleines,
oder eine weitere Ausgabe von unserer Ukraine Kabarett hier bieten, einfach um nicht zu viel auch geschehen äh zu lassen, bevor man sich dazu äußert, denn.
Das eben so ist in Kriegszeiten, die Dinge ändern sich schnell. So, mit von der Partie ist natürlich Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Fünf Tage sind jetzt äh vergangen, also wir haben heute den 9. März, gegen
81 Uhr nehmen wir das hier auf. Ich glaube, das war ganz wichtig, dass man auch mal so eine konkrete Zeitmarke nennt, weiß der Geier, was dann schon wieder alles passiert ist. Ähm am 4. März, am Freitag, also vor fünf Tagen, haben wir die letzte Sendung aufgenommen.
Dann ähm Folgetag veröffentlicht. Ja, nachdem wir in der ersten Sendung.
Erstmal versucht haben, alles ein wenig zusammenzufegen, was denn überhaupt da so die Gesamtsituation ist. Kann man natürlich jetzt sehr viel mehr in die.
Diskussion einzelner hm Fortschritte oder Rückschritte, je nachdem wie man's sehen will, die sich so ergeben haben.
Ähm vielleicht zu Beginn, wir hatten letztes Mal so äh du hattest am Schluss noch so gesagt, na ja diesmal können wir uns ja auch noch mal über die Schuldfrage unterhalten.
Ja ich ich denke es ist es ist wichtiger jetzt ähm nach vorne zu gucken erstmal in die in die Zukunft so ähm weil die Schuldfrage ist äh wie gesagt,
kompliziert, dass es äh das ist dann fast ein ja ein historischer Exkurs eigentlich äh durch die letzten Jahrhunderte ähm.
Auch russischer Geschichte und,
Geschichte und dann natürlich ja äh der äh deutschen Wiedervereinigung und was dann äh sagen ist der Fall der Sowjetunion und da gibt's gibt's eben so viele Aspe
die da rein spielen, so viele Verträge, die geschlossen wurden, die man die man erwähnen und kommentieren muss und ähm ja ich,
Ich denke, das hat aber im Moment auch nicht nicht wirklich Priorität äh sondern das ist eine Debatte, die können wir dann mal.
Ausführlicher führen so wenn die Dinge sich etwas verlangsamt äh haben äh und im Moment.
Passieren ja immer äh noch fast täglich neue Dinge und neue Aspekte tauchen auf und.
Insofern denke ich, ist wichtiger, dass wir die erst mal covern und natürlich gucken, okay, wie kann das denn jetzt überhaupt weitergehen
so das finde ich halt äh fast wichtiger oder interessanter gerade so. Wo stehen wir? Wobei wir vielleicht die Frage so ein bisschen äh auch auch Streifen äh werden oder sollten im,
Zusammenhang jetzt mit den.
Kurz mit den Monaten äh vor der Invasion äh so was was da los war, was da die Situation eigentlich gewesen ist. Da kann man sicherlich mal kurz
eingehen, aber äh viel weiter zurück würde ich jetzt im Moment nicht nicht unbedingt gehen wollen, auch nicht durch die
ukrainische Geschichte, allein den Maidan und dann die ganzen äh verschiedenen Präsidentschaften in der Ukraine und was welcher Präsident gemacht hat und so. Das ist halt alles sehr sehr,
ähm kompliziert.
Richtig, aber genau dieser Punkt, diese dieser Zeitraum jetzt in den letzten Tagen, dem haben wir jetzt auch noch nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit,
zumal es auch nicht klar war, was jetzt eigentlich da wirklich konkret passiert ist, ne? Es gab halt seit Dezember
gab's so die äh Berichte, dass die Russen halt Truppen zusammenziehen an der Grenze und dann eben auch in Weißrussland et cetera und äh im zunehmenden Maße hat sich das dann eben zu so einer
Geschichte äh verdichtet, wo Europa und die USA der Meinung war, okay, alles klar, da braut sich was zusammen.
Es gab halt sehr unterschiedliche Einschätzungen darüber, was genau sich da zusammenbraut.
Man da jetzt wirklich äh sieht und was man davon zu halten hat und relativ offensichtlich, dass es halt Leute gab, die früh gesagt haben, hier einschließlich der Ukraine, die wollen uns überfallen. Das wird alles ganz schlimm. Und genauso gab's natürlich auch Leute eben gesagt.
Ja, nee, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen und so. Ähm gut, das ist jetzt klar. Wer da Recht gehabt hat, die Frage ist, was ist dann,
in dem Moment vorher passiert, als allen irgendwie auch klar wurde und genug Intelligence da war. Ich meine, die Amerikaner haben ja.
Wurde ja zumindest bekannt, eine Woche vorher relativ klar gesagt, so hier am was ich glaube, die Aussage war ursprünglich am 22. greifen sie an, ne? Was ist ja relativ,
gut getroffen hat, warum auch immer es dann zwei Tage später wurden.
Oder inwiefern denn Informationen halt vielleicht falsch weitergereicht wurde, aber es war relativ klar, der Westen sah die Bedrohung.
An und es sind ja Gespräche geführt worden. Es ist viel hin und her geflogen worden. Man saß an langen Tischen et cetera.
Genau und das hat
das wird ja niemandem entgangen haben, das dann äh schon im Vorfeld es eine Krisendiplomatie gab äh wie ja lange nicht mehr. Da haben sich ja hat sich ja ein Staatschef nach dem anderen äh die Hand,
Klinke in die Hand gegeben bei Putin, aber auch in den Monaten davor, als sich das so zusammenbraute, ähm hat,
man so vom Westen aus her äh wohl schon eine ganze Menge Angebote unterbreitet, die jetzt nicht so in der Presse unbedingt,
breit,
wurden, aber äh in Expertenkreisen ist halt jetzt bekannt geworden, so was äh was für Angebote da auf den Tisch gelegt äh wurden. Ähm und,
Dazu gehörten so Angebote wie äh Sicherheitsgarantien für die Krim und äh für Luhansk und äh Donezk,
Ähm plus äh Angebote, NATO-Truppen, von den Grenzen zu Russland.
Zu ziehen und zu beschränken und ähm.
Über äh Gespräche, über Raketenstationierungen, dass man die weiter weg von Russland äh hinstellt oder den bestimmt. Also da gab's,
wirklich ganz, ganz viele Angebote, die nicht so breit getreten wurden, weil man jetzt auch nicht so in der Öffentlichkeit äh jetzt nicht so schwach äh erscheinen äh wollte, aber ja.
Es gab äh haufenweise Angebote und Putin ist auf kein.
Angebot wirklich eingegangen, so dort dort ernsthaft drüber zu reden oder zu verhandeln so von äh so, weil äh da.
War wohl schon klar. Oder ihm war wohl schon klar, was er vorhat.
Und wollte sich jetzt nicht irgendwie davon auch noch abhalten äh lassen. Ich glaube, das war halt schon genug, dass er dann seinen Gesprächspartnern, seinen hochrangigen Offen ins Gesicht
gelogen hat und wollte dann vielleicht auch nicht noch irgendwie eventuell noch irgendwelche Verträge oder oder Zusagen oder so äh machen im Vorfeld, von denen er wusste, dass er ohnehin nicht gedenkt die ähm
einzuhalten und ähm ja, die Vermutung war ja auch, äh dass er,
auch mit die die Unruhen oder den den den Kriegszustand,
im Ostteil der Ukraine unter anderem deswegen auch mit aufrecht erhält und und und mit befeuert, um dann äh gegebenenfalls äh dann auch einen Grund zu haben äh für einen Einmarsch.
Ähm und.
Zwei Dinge äh waren halt äh wohl noch also einmal die Verschiebung, was du gesagt hattest, da ist die Vermutung, dass tatsächlich äh er,
verschoben hat, um einen Tag nachdem der äh Termin bekannt geworden ist. So.
Und äh dass halt auch im Vorfeld hm die Amerikaner recht gut Bescheid wussten
um äh so geplante Falls Fleck-Operationen, die er durchführen und provozieren wollte und haben das halt.
Öffentlich äh gemacht, äh sodass er letztlich auch dann davon abgehalten äh wurde, so ja
aller äh noch Gleiwitz oder so irgendwelche Soldaten reinzuschicken, die dann irgendwie
äh brutalst ermordet werden oder irgendwelche Gräueltaten oder so was an der russischen Bevölkerung. Also da hat denke ich
auch äh so die Veröffentlichung von Geheiminformationen, obwohl man das ja ungerne macht, ähm weil das möglicherweise Quellen gefährdet, äh hat man da aber die Strategiegefahren von Seiten der USA, vor allem.
Ähm die Information, die man hatte dann auch öffentlich zu machen, was dann natürlich Putin dazu bewegt hat
zum einen zu verschieben oder bestimmte Dinge einfach nicht zu tun, nachdem äh die Amerikaner angekündigt hatten, dass er das tun wird, so äh hat er die Sachen abgesagt
weil das wäre natürlich dann blöd gewesen, äh wenn die Amerikaner dann plötzlich Recht gehabt.
Beziehungsweise war da natürlich der Überraschungseffekt weg. Also das fand ich auch nochmal eine eine ganz interessante Sache, dass da
durch Bekanntgabe seiner Pläne viele vereitelt worden sind. Ähm.
Ja, was natürlich eine interessante Strategie ist, ne? Na ja, klar
Aber grad solche Falsfleck äh Operationen, ich meine, das ist nun wirklich ja auch eine Methode, mit der er ganz klar
äh arbeitet, ne, abgesehen davon, dass die Propaganda in in Russland halt alles verbreiten darf, was ihn gerade so in den Kram passt und das Ganze halt die ganze Zeit immer so unter diesem Aspekt mit ja, ist ja alles Nazis und die müssen ja alle befreit werden.
Ähm so äh gestreut würden die Leute das ja auch teilweise fressen.
Ja und vielleicht.
Auch noch mal so zum Schulthema, weil das auch Teil der der Kommentare jetzt war äh zur zur letzten Sendung äh nämlich was hat es jetzt mit den ganzen Nazis in der Ukraine auf sich und.
Da habe ich auch nie einen Heal raus gemacht, ja äh da gab es äh.
Gibt es auch, wenn man so was wie Neonazis oder eher sagen rechtsextremisten oder ultra Nationalisten, die,
schon auch immer ein gewisses Problem für jede Regierung äh darstellten und äh mit denen sich
im Übrigen auch Selenski auseinandersetzen musste. Also die waren jetzt auch keine keine großen Freunde, aber gerade auch in einem Land wie
der Ukraine.
Die natürlich dann auch noch teilweise besetzt ist, ist das halt auch nochmal krass. Wir gerne wissen, wie hier in Deutschland die Nazis toben würden, wenn
weiß ich nicht, Russland sich jetzt irgendwie Sachsen holt äh um dort zu entnazifizieren oder so und äh ja.
Und dann äh also natürlich erzeugen äh dann solche solche Polarisierungen stärken. Natürlich auch die extremen Ränder, aber.
Interessanterweise wir haben zumindest diese Neonazis oder die die ultra Nationalisten haben dort politisch in den Wahlen jetzt nicht,
wirklich Prozente geholt. Also äh biegt sich dann eher im im Ein-Prozent-Bereich und haben da jetzt auch nicht wirklich politischen Einfluss. So und ja.
Auch die Ukraine war äh uns mit äh Trump zu sagen ein Shithole in vielerlei Hinsicht ähm,
aber hat sich versucht eben.
Schon daraus zu arbeiten und schon auch Korruption äh zu bekämpfen und die Oligarchen und aber so richtig ähm moralisch sauber war da.
Niemand, ja. Nur hm,
der Punkt, warum ich das jetzt für auch nicht mehr so relevant halte, ist dass mit dem,
mit der Invasion hm.
Diese ganzen Sünden getilgt wurden, ja? So Selenskis Fehler ähm die er gemacht hat auch und da gibt es eine ganze Menge. Ich meine ja unerfeierte.
Nicht wirklich erstmal Ahnung von dem, was er tut und er hatte ja auch in den Oligarchen den mit an die Macht äh gebracht hat und ähm da war jetzt auch nicht,
irgendwie alles äh äh sauber und rein und einwandfrei, aber das ist jetzt mehr oder weniger irrelevant geworden, auch weil es,
faktisch nur einen Vorwand
gewesen ist von von Putin und äh ja eigentlich ganz offensichtlich ist, dass da keine Drogensüchtigen äh Terroristen und Nazis gejagt werden.
So dafür braucht man keine 200.000 Mann Armee und insbesondere sind die jetzt auch nicht nicht wirklich an der Regierung und,
Ja, die das die Diskussion jetzt wie das dann in den in den Vorjahren gelaufen ist. Äh wie gesagt, die glaube ich.
Kriegen wir jetzt nicht geführt äh gerade im im Moment, die müssten wir dann dann leider noch mal ein ein bisschen,
schieben, weil das ist dann wirklich Ritt und Galopp durch die durch die Geschichte der auch eine Menge Vorbereitung äh noch braucht, den man nicht so einfach äh ausm Handgelenk schütteln kann, auch mit,
Ja den entsprechenden Dokumenten und Verträgen in die man dann da reingucken muss und die man dann äh kommentieren muss und die ganzen Akteure, die dann da drin waren, also sich so vom Budapest herabkommen äh bis zu den äh,
zwei plus vier Verträgen und äh KSZE Schlussakte und,
äh ja ungefähr noch einen Dutzend anderer Verträge, die in dem Kontext relevant sind. Muss man sich eigentlich ähm alle zumindest.
Anschauen, so worum's worum's da geht und wer wem was versprochen hat, zu welcher Zeit und so, das ist halt ein ein Riesenkomplexes Thema und ähm,
Ja, aber es ist wie gesagt jetzt halt nicht mehr wirklich.
Oder aktuell nicht nicht so relevant, weil äh will nicht sagen, das ist Schnee von gestern, aber das diese Aufbereitung hat glaube ich noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Okay, gut. Ähm in den Links ein Interview was ist das, äh Deutsche Welle mit der Sicherheitsexpertin, Konstanze Stelzenmüller, wo so ein paar Aspekte von denen du jetzt gerade genannt hast, auch wiedergegeben werden?
Ja, das ist.
Äh Interview aber ich meine das ist Englisch, obwohl es drei Deutsche Welle äh ist und sie glaube ich auch deutschstämmig ist. Aber das fand ich
bisher das kompakteste und beste, was ich so gefunden habe an.
Experten Kommentar insbesondere zur politischen Lage und politischen äh Gesamtsituationen. Also kann ich auch.
Jedem nur empfehlen, der das englischen mächtig ist, da einfach mal reinzuhören äh und vieles davon werden wir, glaube ich, auch hier nochmal aufgreifen und und wiedergeben, aber das ist sozusagen auch die die Quelle jetzt für
ganze Menge von von Dingen oder oder Einschätzungen, wobei es nicht die einzige Quelle ist, sondern sich das halt sehr gut,
eben auch mit dem, was viele andere Experten und äh Kommentatoren äh sagen, aber sie hat es halt wirklich sehr sehr gut auf den Punkt,
gebracht und auch mit großer Offenheit so ganz ganz viele ähm heikle Fragen äh dort sehr gut beantwortet.
Finde ich die Berichterstattung von Deutsche Welle ziemlich gut. Also gar nicht erst in diesem Krieg, sondern generell eigentlich ist es so ein bisschen unter dem Radar würde ich sagen.
Ja, also für für einen Deutschen Propaganda-Sender gar nicht schlecht, muss man sagen.
Ja
Also auch die Coronakrise und so, also die ganzen Specials, die sie da immer wieder rausgebracht haben alles so im besten Sinne äh ruhig. Man ist so so ein bisschen das Format.
Das ist so auch wie äh hier Francs twenty-four.
Ne? So diese ganzen Versuche der einzelnen europäischen größeren Länder in irgendeiner Form auf ich sage mal auf BBC World zu machen.
Ne? Das ist so sicherlich immer der ähm.
Heimliche Vorbild auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise äh und klar, wie das eben so ist. Bei Deutsche Welle sieht man aber eben dann sehr viel mehr Leute so aus dem deutschen.
Kulturraum, die in irgendeiner Form eben die internationale Situation beleuchten und allein allein deshalb finde ich das schon interessant, ne, weil das sieht man ja sonst eigentlich so in den Nachrichten nicht so oft.
Ja aber eigentlich darf die Deutsche Welle ja in Deutschland gar nicht verbreitet werden oder senden, weil es sich halt um Staatsrundfunk handelt und äh ja.
Habe ich auch schwarz geguckt im Internet.
Ja dann gab's relativ kurz nach Veröffentlichung unserer letzten Sendung gab es so ein interessantes Leak dem wohl.
Viele Quellen äh attestiert haben, das ist recht glaubwürdig ist.
Angeblich ein Mitarbeiter aus dem FSB, aus dieser KGB Geheimdienstnachfolger.
Und der hat halt so einen längeren längeren Bericht abgegeben wie er die Lage einschätzt der ganzen russischen Kampagne nach der nach den ersten zehn Tagen oder so.
Und äh ja.
Ja ich würde würde eher sagen, er hat sich ausgekotzt.
Das.
Also das Management Summery ist äh alles, alles, alles im Eimer. Äh Hilfe, so. Also er berichtet von einem großen Durcheinander in der Armee, was vor allem dadurch äh getragen ist, dass halt,
keiner genau wusste, was überhaupt Phase ist. Diese gesamte ähm das gesamte Kriegsszenario wurde also auch höheren Rängen im.
Militär vorenthalten. Niemand wusste sozusagen, dass es wirklich darum ging. Alle haben sich mehr oder weniger,
auf äh ja Militärübungen befunden. Inwiefern das dann alle auch wirklich geglaubt haben, kann ich natürlich nicht sagen, aber es war jetzt auch nicht so, dass alle da saßen und wussten so, morgen überfallen wir hier unser Nachbarland.
Sich darauf schon mal einstellen können, sondern es äh ging halt einfach irgendwann der Befehl, ach ja übrigens äh schön, dass ihr da gerade rumhängt. Äh wir marschieren jetzt übrigens mal in die Ukraine ein.
Und äh auch der Anteil von sehr unerfahrenen.
Soldaten, sehr jungen Soldaten äh scheint wohl relativ hoch zu sein.
Man tatsächlich
worum ich mich also worüber ich mich gewundert hatte, war als dann im Internet halt diese Wehrpflichtigen, die dann gefangen genommen worden waren in der Ukraine, präsentiert wurden und ich fragte hä,
kann das sein, dass da Wehrpflichtige in der Ukraine sind, wo doch
äh in Russland gesetzlich verboten ist, Wehrpflichtige im Ausland einzusetzen und ich dachte hm okay also entweder hat,
Putin ähm die Ukraine nicht als Ausland äh definiert, aber nee, so war es, so war es nicht. Sondern was sie wohl gemacht haben, war zum einen
die ganzen Wehrpflichtigen, äh die sie brauchten, mehr oder weniger zu drängen oder zu erpressen, äh dann.
Zeitvertrag
unterschreiben, weil wie gesagt nur Berufs- und Zeitsoldaten dürfen eigentlich im Ausland eingesetzt werden und da haben dann eben verschiedene da äh auch davon berichtet, also verschiedene gefangene Soldaten äh das, wie sie halt gedrängt worden sind äh dann diesen Zeitvertrag zu unterschreiben, aber,
werden die Russen nicht die Russen, wenn sie nicht auch das äh äh verkackt hätten
weil äh jetzt musste sich gestern dann der russische Verteidigungsminister dafür entschuldigen, dass wohl auch
Wehrpflichtige kurzzeitig in der Ukraine waren, aber sie sind jetzt alle wieder abgezogen worden. Also sie Wehrpflichtigen sind jetzt nicht mehr da. So während nach das alles nach dem Putin einen Tag vorher gesagt hat, denn eine sind keine Wehrpflichtigen in der EU.
Ukraine. Also das ist dann auch schon ein Thema
das durchaus in in Russland dann schon natürlich auch kontrovers ist, weil wie gesagt
Pitt nachgesetzt dürfen da halt Wehrpflichtige nicht nicht ins Ausland und ganz offensichtlich ja waren da welche und ähm.
Und fand ich aber bemerkenswert, dass der Verteidigungsminister das tatsächlich auch eingeräumt hat, also so ganz hundertprozentig äh scheint dann die.
Bereitschaft zum Lügen auch nicht zu sein. Weil gut, es ist aber auch dann war vielleicht auch dann zu offensichtlich. Ähm.
So dass äh ja dass da Wehrpflichtige waren und ähm aber ansonsten ja,
gibt's ja auch wenig Skrupel irgendwie beliebig zu lügen, deswegen fand ich das jetzt sehr bemerkenswert.
Bericht hat auf jeden Fall auch nochmal festgestellt, was wir eigentlich ja auch schon angesprochen hatten, dass also hier ein Blitzkrieg geplant war, dass dieser aber
total fehlgeschlagen ist, dass sie einfach das mit ihrer ganzen Logistik nicht auf die Kette gebracht haben und jetzt
Stecken sie halt irgendwie fest. So eine Mobilmachung wäre wohl erforderlich, aber sei irgendwie nicht möglich, weil die von der Bevölkerung nicht mitgetragen würde und generell
sei einfach auch die Logistik überlastet so und ähm sie hätten auch sehr hohe Verluste.
Gibt's natürlich keine gesicherten Zahlen, Ukraine behauptet ja schon seit längerem, da werden über 10.000 Leute gestorben. Also in der russischen Armee.
So so viele also ähm ich habe jetzt von den Amerikanern äh Zahlen gehört, die Amerikaner gehen bisher von mindestens 3000 äh gefallenen Russen aus. Also zwischen zwei und dreitausend.
Waren die letzten Zahlen, aber sind auch schon ein paar Tage alt.
Aber es ist trotzdem eine Menge.
Während die Russen äh äh nicht wirklich Zahlen äh rausgeben, aber so eher von einigen hundert äh äh.
Ich glaube 600 ist so eine Zahl, die sie war. Habe fallen lassen.
Allerdings hat äh Putin ja auch so eine bemerkenswerte Rede dann dann gehalten so nach einer nach einer Woche ungefähr wo er dann lang und breit geschildert hat.
Welche Entschädigung jetzt Gefallenen oder verletzten Soldaten und ihren Angehörigen.
Zusteht. Also mit wie Summen okay und die Familie kriegt so und so viel und Verletzte kriegen halt eine Rente in der und der Höhe und äh ja dann Witwen und Waisenrente. Ich dachte nur
oh oh.
Ähm also so oft, wie er dann auch tot erwähnt hat dadrin. So habe ich mich gefragt, okay, das ist das jetzt, das ist jetzt vermutlich schon dann Teil auch der Vorbereitung der Bevölkerung darauf, dass es wohl noch mehr Todesopfer
geben wird, weil offensichtlich das war jetzt nicht mehr unter dem unter dem Deckel äh zu halten.
Die Verluste sind auf jeden Fall real, das das sieht man ja auch schon aus den äh Bildern, inwiefern man das zuverlässig quantifizieren kann. Glaube, dass.
Das kann keiner derzeit tun. Dazu ist einfach die Interessenlage und Informationslage zu durcheinander.
Ja und äh der dieser Geheimdienstler meinte, die Russen wüssten's selber nicht.
Könnten selber nicht genau sagen, wie viele Gefallene äh das jetzt sind und.
Es gibt interessanterweise jetzt auch die äh die Ukraine hat eine Hotline eingerichtet,
wo jetzt unter anderem auch Russen oder russische Eltern anrufen können und sich äh erkundigen können, ob dann ihre Kinder oder Ehemänner oder.
In Gefangenschaft sind.
In Gefangenschaft oder Gefallen äh sind so und,
da äh äh gibt's dann halt äh wohl mittlerweile jetzt viele Anrufe aus aus aller Welt auch. Viele von eben Exil-Russen, aber viele auch,
allen Teilen Russlands eigentlich, wo dann Eltern nachfragen, die äh Kontakt zu ihren Kindern äh oder Eheleuten verloren haben und jetzt seit Wochen nichts mehr gehört,
haben und äh sich sich Sorgen machen
sich aber auch nicht trauen ähm beim russischen Verteidigungsministerium anzurufen aus Angst dann Ärger zu kriegen, rufen sie dann lieber in der Ukraine an bei der Hotline, ob die nichts wissen, zufällig.
Das fand ich auch ziemlich krass. Wobei sie natürlich in den meisten Fällen nicht nicht wirklich weiterhelfen können, aber eine Aufgabe der Hotline ist halt auch dann so die Anrufer dann darüber zu informieren, was denn so gerade wirklich los ist in der Ukraine.
Ja, also das ist.
Also das er meint auch, also in der nächsten Woche würde sich das in irgendeiner Form auch äh entscheiden müssen, in welche Richtung das kippt, was überhaupt
diese Woche äh betrifft, gibt's so einige interessante Vorhersagen, auch was die Auswirkungen der Sanktionen betrifft. Da vielleicht gleich noch mal zu. Ansonsten meint er
in diesem Bericht, diese Person, wer auch immer das sein mag, äh unsere relative Deadline ist irgendwie bis bis Juni, weil im Juni.
Wenn wir keine Wirtschaft mehr haben, zwar gar nichts mehr.
Das ist halt auch schon so eine Erkenntnis, die sich durch dort durchsetzt, dass einfach durch die internationalen Sanktionen, die wirklich krass sind, eigentlich.
Die russische Wirtschaft zurecht keinerlei Möglichkeit hat zu äh überleben.
Und die letzten Tage waren ja auch jetzt äh gepflastert mit äh weiteren,
Fabrikschließung, paar Sachen hatten wir ja letztes Mal schon erwähnt zu IKEA und so und mittlerweile äh werden jetzt auch diese ganzen anderen Franchises ähm dazu gezwungen ihre Läden dort zu schließen, McDonald's.
Sicherlich fast mit das Symbolischste, ja, das müsste man nur noch Coca-Cola überredet bekommen, dann.
Ja, also Pep Pepsi hat Pepsi hat wohl schon eingestellt und ich glaube, Coca-Cola hat jetzt auch nachgezogen meine ich äh gehört.
Okay, das habe ich noch nicht gehört, aber.
Sich dem Druck, also Pepsi war wohl vorher und dann hat wohl Coca-Cola irgendwie jetzt heute glaube ich nach.
Und Starbucks und so. Ich meine, da kann man jetzt ein bisschen drüber schmunzeln, aber das ist natürlich auch ein interessantes Signal an,
an die russische Bevölkerung, ne. Die sehen halt auf einmal überall diese Symbole der der internationalisierung und auch sagen wir mal der der Globalisierung im positiven Sinne, also das so nach dem Motto, wir nehmen daran jetzt auch teil, dass die halt jetzt alle verschwinden und,
letzte Mal schon klar war, was wir glaube ich nicht erwähnt haben, ist was weiß ich, Volkswagen hat ja auch ein großes Werk. Das steht jetzt still et cetera.
Col Bär meinte irgendwie zu äh zum Thema McDonald's okay, ganz ganz Russland ist jetzt eine No-Frizon.
Oh Gott.
Okay ähm aber sind wir jetzt eigentlich in dem Punkt Auswirkungen äh der der Sanktionen jetzt schon mittendrin.
Na ja ich wollte jetzt mal kurz nur seine
also die in diesem Bericht engagiert und diese Selbsteinschätzung vornehmen, weil die war ja relativ klar ja und vor allem zeigt sie auch nochmal ganz unabhängig von dem, was drin steht. Zeigt's ja vor allem auch nochmal,
relativ deutlich, dass es auch in Russland da in innerhalb des gesamten Staatsgefüges auch ganz unterschiedliche Gruppen gibt. Also offensichtlich war der Geheimdienst.
Russlands wusste nicht, dass das Land gleich einen Krieg führt.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen. Also der KGB, der FSB wusste nicht, dass Russland gleichen Krieg führt. Alle waren völlig unvorbereitet und er schrieb ja auch, es gab zwar vorher von Seiten der Politik.
So Anfragen mit ja mach doch mal eine Einschätzung, was wäre denn wenn diese und diese wenn jetzt so Sanktionen vom Westen kommen? Wie können wir denn damit umgehen? Aber die waren halt alle nicht jetzt konkret auf das Ziel Ukraine?
Gemünzt.
Es war so eher so, er bezeichnet das so, okay, was passiert, wenn hier oder hier ein Meteorit einschlägt? So.
Und deswegen haben die das halt auch nicht alle wirklich ernst genommen
so, sondern haben dann halt wohl geschrieben, was sie glaubten, dass die Vorgesetzten hören wollen, weil äh
ich meine wozu auch? Wenn so völlig hypothetische äh Szenarien oder oder oder Anfragen äh gestellt werden, dann ja.
Wozu dann irgendwie sich sich durch die Wahrheit äh Unannehmlichkeiten einhandeln. Weil,
natürlich ja wird wohl äh mit dem
Überbringer ja unangenehmer Nachrichten so also Wahrheit verteilt allgemein wohl nicht wirklich geschätzt oder steht nicht in einem besonders hohen Kurs in der äh russischen
Administration.
Genau und uns zeigt sich vor allem, dass es auch dort verschiedene Lager gibt. Das heißt, innerhalb dieses Gesamtkräfte äh Spiels einfach ich meine, wenn der ganze FSB äh außen vorgehalten wird, das sagt ja auch schon was darüber aus. Also es macht einen zunehmenden Maße den Eindruck.
Dass das Ganze wirklich in einem extrem kleinen Kreis geplant.
Beziehungsweise beschlossen wurde und deswegen wurde gar nicht geplant. Weil man hätte ja mehr Leute davon wissen lassen müssen, um auch wirklich einen Plan zu machen.
Halt Konsequenzen dabei raus, für die keiner vorgesorgt hat, wo keiner vorher sich drüber Gedanken gemacht hat, weil das Thema so nie aufm Tisch war.
Ja? Es gab wohl äh schon länger Pläne für eine Invasion im im Süden. So um dort
die das alles zu konsolidieren, also von einer Krim aus
und da hat man dementsprechend auch Militärbasen errichtet und da ist der Boden auch ein bisschen besser und da gab's einen Plan. Also für den wohl für den Südteil gab's auch einen einen Plan.
Aber für,
alles, was da im im im Norden wohl gekommen ist. Das ist wohl eher äh notdürftig zusammengezimmert worden.
So und äh da war glaube ich nicht so ganz klar, wie das wie das laufen soll, aber vor allen Dingen wurde halt eben auf Basis äh völlig falscher Annahmen.
Na gut, also wir haben Links für euch ähm auf Übersetzung auch von diesem Bericht, der hatte ich in Russisch gehalten ist und es gibt eine englische Übersetzung, es gibt auch eine deutsche Übersetzung. Kann man das mal nachlesen äh ist ziemlich dramatisch.
Ja ich fand die englische irgendwie komischerweise verständlicher. Ich weiß nicht, ob das an der Art der Übersetzung äh äh ins Deutsche lag, aber im im deutschen klang's halt irgendwie ein bisschen sperrig das Ganze, ein bisschen.
Komisch, aber äh ja.
Inhalt ist aber der gleiche. Ja dann kommen wir nochmal zu den Auswirkungen der Sanktionen.
Zeichnet sich in zunehmendem Maße ab, dass das diesmal wirklich Auswirkungen hat. Haben wir ja im Prinzip letztes Mal auch schon angesprochen.
Gibt es auch schon Einschätzungen, dass das äh schon in dieser Woche auch zu Bankencrashes.
Führen könnte. Die ganzen Ratingagenturen haben mittlerweile Russland so auf dem allerletzten Rang vor kurz vor boycropped.
Ne, also sie sind quasi kurz vor Zahlungsunfähigkeit und das ist auch durchaus damit zu rechnen, dass diese Zahlungsunfähigkeit demnächst festgestellt wird.
Mir ist nicht so ganz so sicher, was das für eine Auswirkung äh hat. Also ich habe das so verstanden, dass ähm wenn jetzt.
Nicht mehr in der Lage ist seine Schulden zu bezahlen. Also seine Staatsschulden, Anleihen, die sie halt irgendwo aufgenommen haben auf der Welt und für die sie ja regelmäßig ähm ihre ihre.
Rückzahlungsbeiträge zahlen müssen. Wenn Sie diese Kohle nicht haben, weil Sie ja quasi auf ihre Divisen nicht zugreifen können, weil Sie ihr Gold nicht in die Wiesen umwandeln können und äh,
Das dann sonst nur in Rubeln machen, aber der Rubel halt zunehmenden Maße weniger wert ist, dann ja, dann fallen halt diese Zahlungen aus. Was passiert dann? Dann.
Ja, es ist ich meine äh kann man halt.
In die Geschichte gucken. So Argentinien hat das ja irgendwann mal gemacht, äh so Haiti hat das äh irgendwann
auch äh gemacht oder versucht und äh ähm ja bei bei Haiti äh gab's dann daraufhin äh eine,
Invasion.
Ähm weil die ihre Kredite nicht bezahlt haben und Argentinien, da wurde ja äh weiß ich nicht, dann Jahrzehnte lang äh drüber vor verschiedenen Gerichten verhandelt,
am am Ende und
da gab's dann so Aktionen wie das dann argentinisches Staatseigentum irgendwo äh Schiffe und Flugzeuge, die dann irgendwo zufällig gelandet sind, dann beschlagnahmt oder
fändet äh wurden und so, das ist dann halt alles sehr äh un.
Und das äh wird aber wahrscheinlich dann noch ähm ja lange lange äh äh dauern ähm,
viele, viele Gerichtsverfahren und das kann Jahrzehnte dauern bis das dann aussortiert ist. Aber.
Der Effekt ist natürlich, wenn du das einmal machst, leiht dir keiner mehr Geld.
Das ist halt das Problem, insbesondere auch die Chinesen nicht, ja? Weil ähm.
Jetzt auch mal spekuliert, okay die Chinesen könnten jetzt einspringen und ihnen helfen, aber die Chinesen haben halt auch.
Äh die dann die Kredite organisieren und die wollen das Geld natürlich auch zurückhaben, beziehungsweise die äh müssen dann diese Kredite auch äh in ihre Bilanzen entsprechend einstellen.
Und äh wenn du da halt Ramschkredite stehen hast, die halt äh dann dann kriegst du das auch nicht refinanziert nirgendwo. Das heißt, äh das zieht dich halt dann als als ausländische Bank
auch runter. Da müsste dann schon der chinesische Staat dann irgendwo direkt.
Einspringen und irgendwie aber die Chinesen so
so dick Freunde sind sie jetzt auch nicht mit den Russen, dass wenn's denn ums Geld geht ähm ja zumal Chinesen jetzt auch.
In zweierlei Richtungen reagiert äh haben, so zum zum einen äh mögen die Chinesen jetzt nicht so grundsätzlich nicht, wenn die territoriale Integrität von irgendwas
gefährdet oder wenn wenn sich da Dinge
abspalten und das dann anerkannt wird, so dass dass es nicht gut, weil die Chinesen natürlich immer denken, okay wir haben hier äh sozusagen auch wir sind groß genug, wir haben irgendwie,
auch genug,
Landesteile, die sich gerne abspalten würden und da wollen wir jetzt irgendwie gar keinen Präzedenzfall äh rausmachen und weshalb die,
China auch sagen Krim nicht die Abspaltung der Krim nicht anerkannt hat und jetzt auch die äh abgespaltenen Ostprovinzen auch nicht anerkennt.
Nur mal so äh zur Frage jetzt jetzt China. Aber wir waren ja jetzt bei den bei den Folgen, also ganz ganz konkret.
So ein so ein Ding auch von gestern so äh habe ich gehört von meiner Cousine in Prag. Die hat halt ihre äh ihr Haus.
Mit einer russischen Bank finanziert und die russische Banken sind auch in Tschechien zum Beispiel recht,
tief und diese Bank hat jetzt ihren Geschäftsbetrieb eingestellt oder musste ihren Geschäftsbetrieb einstellen, weil sie pleite ist.
Und,
irgendwie erstmal ganz panisch, auch weil sie an ihr Guthaben äh nicht mehr rankommt, als sie dann zur Bank war, stand da schon auch noch eine lange Schlange, aber sind erstmal beruhigt
weil äh wenn du da eine Hypothek hast, das wird dann halt auch interessant, was es wenn deine Bank dann äh sagen Pleite macht, klar, es kommt dann irgendwann die Insolvenzverwalter und wird das versuchen
natürlich einzutreiben, aber erstmal äh ja
Ähm kann man da glaube ich entspannt sein, wenn äh man
Darlehen bei einer russischen Bank aufgenommen hat. Wobei die das zwar auch gekündigt äh haben, dann natürlich aber äh ja, dass es sorgt sozusagen auch.
Jetzt in in westlichen Ländern für für Probleme, aber äh genauso,
natürlich dann für Verbraucher hm in äh Russland, wenn dann wenn dann auch einzelne Banken äh sich jetzt zerlegen. Aber
Staatspleite ist äh hast du angesprochen hast, das ist natürlich etwas äh.
Was dein Land auf lange, lange Sicht.
Von internationalen Kredit äh märkten und Kapital abschneidet, selbst wenn alle Sanktionen aufgehoben werden, wirkt das nach.
Es gehört halt dann jetzt auch zu den nicht so leicht wieder rückgängig zu machenden Schäden, die jetzt eingetreten sind bereit.
Ja die ähm also ich habe das auch so gehört, dass äh wenn jetzt quasi Russland seine Schulden nicht begleichen kann, dass das sein kann, dass dann.
Diese nicht geleisteten Gelder dann eben aus diesen Reserven rausgenommen werden, die überall eingefroren worden sind.
Davon gehe ich aus.
Frage ist, wer entscheidet das.
Äh dass äh werden äh weiß gar nicht welche Gerichte dafür zuständig sind, aber,
in diesen in den ganzen Verträgen sind natürlich auch erstmal so in der Regel dann teilweise auch
Mediatoren erstmal oder Mediationen vorgesehen und dann entsprechend auch äh ja Standorte, wo dann der der Gerichtsstand ist, wo das dann vor Gericht verhandelt wird.
Und äh ja ähm und da gehe ich mal davon davon davon aus, dass ich dann
Mhm ja diejenigen, die da jetzt irgendwie finanzielle Schäden erleiden, dann tatsächlich an den russischen Devisen Reserven,
güttlich halten werden. Selbe Punkt,
das jetzt ja spekuliert wurde beim letzten Mal erwähnt die, dass ja die Hälfte der russischen Zivilflotte geleast ist und äh das jetzt am darüber spekuliert wird.
Russland diese Flugzeuge jetzt beschlagnahmt und nationalisiert. So und das äh wäre dann wahrscheinlich auch so ein Ding äh.
Wo äh dann ja die Leasinggesellschaften dann versuchen werden mhm,
entsprechend äh sich gütlich zu halten. Vor allen Dingen äh das andere Problem ist, dass diese Flugzeuge hinterher, selbst wenn dann in zwei oder drei Monaten,
das Ganze jetzt,
gelöst werden sollte hm dass die Flugzeuge dann unter Umständen nichts mehr wert sind, weil ähm du ein Flugzeug, was nicht eine einwandfreie Wartungshistorie
hat,
äh wo du nicht sicher sein kannst, ob da nicht vielleicht irgendwelche äh äh komischen Teile eingebaut wurden oder so, äh kriegst du halt international gar nicht mehr zertifiziert äh so, das will keiner haben.
Das heißt, das ist dann auch nochmal so ein so ein so ein Problem plus, dass du's nicht versichert kriegst und nicht damit ins Ausland mehr fliegen kannst. Also es ist dann auch noch mal ein ein,
ein super Fuck-Up.
Ja ins Ausland äh fliegt auch derzeit gar nichts mehr. Also Aeroflot hat die ganzen internationalen Verbindungen eingestellt.
Mag das jetzt auch eine Rolle gespielt haben, dieser Aspekt, aber auch der Aspekt, dass äh ja Versicherungen ein Problem sind, aber auch das.
Mittlerweile auch aktiv Bürger daran hindert auszureisen.
Denn äh es wird in zunehmenden Maße schwierig. Ich meine, du kannst dir vorstellen, so eine aufgeklärte Mittelschicht, die es äh sich schon bisschen westlicher orientiert hat, die hat natürlich den Braten sofort gerochen und sehr viele Leute wollten ausreisen.
Ja, also ich habe gehört, dass die finnische Bahn jetzt die die Taktfrequenz äh verdoppelt hat äh der Züge jetzt äh.
Burg Helsinki. Genau, weil das ist nämlich doch eine der letzten äh Fluchtrouten sozusagen, die funktioniert, wo man am schnellsten zu einem Flughafen kommt mit internationalen Verbindungen, wenn man irgendwo hinfliegen will. Das ist jetzt von russischem Boden aus direkt nicht mehr möglich.
Läuft nicht gut.
Und genau. Was ein bisschen weird ist, ich glaube, das hatten wir letztes Mal auch schon erwähnt, also Mastercard und Visa haben ja.
Glaube, das haben wir letzte Mal haben wir das gesagt, dass das schon nicht mehr funktioniert, tatsächlich ist es dann erst.
Äh in Full-Effekt einen Tag später,
gekommen. Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht mehr ganz so sicher ähm was ich da gehört hatte, ob sich das sozusagen nur abzeichnet oder ob das nur so eine Vorstufe war oder ob sie das angekündigt haben, dass es ein paar Tage nicht funktioniert. Auf jeden Fall die Situation ist jetzt so.
Wenn du in Russland von einer russischen Bank,
Mastercard oder die Visacard bekommen hast, so wie das ja hier eigentlich auch der Fall ist, ne. Hast hier ein Konto, was weiß ich bei der Sparkasse, kriegst von denen eine Kreditkarte. Dann ist die Sparkasse eigentlich dein Partner,
Ja, nur die Sparkasse hat quasi den Vertrag mit Mastercard äh oder eben mit Visa, das über deren Netze diese Zahlung dann abgewickelt werden und damit funktioniert das Ding halt überall in der Welt.
Innerhalb des Landes ist das immer noch ein bisschen was anderes, so wie hier auch mit Girocard und auch die Russen haben ja mittlerweile so ein eigenes Netz gemacht, was sie im Prinzip auch erst gestartet haben nachdem die ersten Sanktionen kamen wegen der Besetzung der Krim zwanzig vierzehn. Mir.
Mhm.
Passenderweise auch noch Friedensnetz genannt. Ähm heißt.
Wenn du jetzt so eine Karte hast, dann kannst du aber damit derzeit immer noch in Russland bezahlen. Mir ist jetzt nicht so ganz klar warum.
Das deshalb, ob das ein Deal ist oder.
Ob das so ein Abfallprodukt der technischen Implementierung ist, dass wenn quasi eine Bezahlung.
Innerhalb Russlands läuft, dass das dann quasi so innerhalb der des russischen Bankensystems direkt unmittelbar abgerechnet wird und gar keinen Zugriff auf die eigentlichen Mastercard-WISA-Netze erfolgt.
Ja
Bisschen meine Vermutung, ich weiß es aber nicht ganz sicher. Ja oder ob sie das laufen lassen.
Würde aber eigentlich nicht dazu passen, dass sie sagen, dass sie ihren Betrieb einstellen. Was auf jeden Fall nicht geht, ist international irgendwas zu bezahlen.
Oder mit einer ausländischen Kreditkarte in Russland zu bezahlen oder mit einer russischen Karte im Ausland
was zu bezahlen. Was natürlich gerade jetzt für die russischen Flüchtlinge ein Problem ist, also die Leute, die jetzt sagen, es geht jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr. Putin steckt uns alle in den Knast, wenn wir was gegen Krieg sagen.
Et cetera. Der letzte mit diesem TV Rain hat irgendwie so der letzte Fernsehsender.
Äh jetzt dicht gemacht nachdem die Duma ein Gesetz beschlossen hat, dass wenn du auch nur irgendwie was sagst, was irgendwie kritisch ist, dann kommst du 15 Jahre in den Knast. Hat ja sogar die Deutsche Welle aufgehört äh zu senden.
Und äh daraufhin ist halt dieser Exodus äh hat begonnen und ja viele haben dann noch die letzten Flüge bekommen. Alle anderen äh versuchen jetzt irgendwie aus dem Landweg.
Das Land zu verlassen inwiefern das jetzt demnächst noch blockiert werden wird, das wird man sehen.
Aber äh das ist jetzt sozusagen die Situation mit diesen Kreditkarten. Ist natürlich jetzt für die Leute, die jetzt ohnehin dem System.
Drinnen wollen äh im Ausland Schutz suchen, aber dann eben keinen Zugriff auf ihre Gelder haben, die
nicht mehr sehr viel wert sind unter Umständen, weil.
Ne, Hobelverfall, aber immerhin, sie hätten ja dann zumindest noch was für die ist es natürlich nochmal besonders schwierig. Da gibt's wohl in einzelnen Ländern so Ansätze. Türkei zum Beispiel, dass.
Geholfen wird, dass so andere Banken das dann irgendwie regeln, wie auch immer, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, äh aber generell ist es für die Leute natürlich.
Schwierig und auch das ist so eine Ausnahme. Das heißt, die Sanktionen sind enorm. Die Sanktionen greifen um sich. Immer mehr internationale Unternehmen ziehen sich zurück, wenn jetzt Coca Cola auch noch zurückzieht. So, dann sind glaube ich fast alle Player,
äh weg. Es sind auch Shell, BP et cetera, alle ziehen sich jetzt aus ihren Kooperationen. Das ist eigentlich der vorprogrammierte ähm Todesstoß.
Und damit.
So ein bisschen auf so einen Verwandtenblock ähm nämlich diese Frage, okay wo kriege ich denn jetzt Russland überhaupt noch Geld her und das ist ja auch gerade so die Diskussion in Deutschland.
Finanzieren das ja alles mit, weil wir kaufen den Russen ja Öl ab und wir kaufen den Russen das Gas ab.
Die USA haben jetzt gesagt, wir kaufen kein Öl mehr aus Russland.
Selber ein Öl produzierendes Land und ich glaube, das macht da so drei Prozent oder so von dem äh aus, was sie da konsumiert haben. Das können die problemlos aus anderen Quellen äh decken. Es war für die Amerikaner jetzt eine relativ.
Einfache Maßnahme in Anführungsstrichen das zu beschließen, weil sie das nicht groß äh kratzt und vom Gas profitieren die ziehen die glaube ich gar nichts.
Ganz im Gegenteil, sind ja selber Gasexporteur in Form dieser LNG, also dieser äh Flüssiggas äh Exporte.
Ja, aber in Europa haben wir natürlich die große Diskussion. Und da muss man dann glaube ich auch generell zwischen Öl und Gas unterscheiden.
Öl hat den Vorteil, für Russland.
Ist so eine globale Infrastruktur. Jeder braucht Öl, überall geht Öl hin.
Jedes Land hat einen Hafen, wo du Öl anliefern kannst, wo du Öl lagern kannst, weil Öl ist halt einfach.
Zahlt Öl. Jeder braucht Öl für alles, für Kunststoffe et cetera, für Energie.
Wobei da wohl auch so ein bisschen das Problem ist, nicht jede Ölsorte ist halt gleich gut.
Und die Raffinerinen sind halt auf einen eine bestimmte Art von Öl eingestellt, weswegen
sagen man man da auch gerne mischt so um halt den den richtigen Blend
zu haben, mit dem die Raffinerie dann gefahren äh werden kann. Das heißt, das ist dann sozusagen auch noch ein Problem, weil wohl teilweise, ich hörte, dass das russische Öl eben
und teilweise auch gerne genutzt wird oder erforderlich ist, um.
Dann halt den richtigen Mix hin äh zu bekommen. Äh ähm.
Schwefelanteil und so was.
Ja, ja, ja,
und ähm ja generell die die Verteilung äh der Kohlenwasserstoffe und so. Aber gut, das ich denke mal, das ist das ist lösbar, aber sind dann sind dann halt.
Ging's jetzt auch eher um diesen logistischen Aspekt. Ja, also Öltanker-Gips, Öltanker können überall anlegen, Öltanker können überall hinfahren. Das ist etwas, das das gibt es und davon gibt es auch genug.
Beim Gas sieht's anders aus. Gas wird primär in Europa über Pipelines angeliefert.
Durch die äh Ukraine. Ähm es gibt ja schon seit längerem auch die durch die Türkei geplante Pipeline, die existiert aber noch nicht, ne.
Also übern Süden läuft auch ein bisschen was äh.
Auch nach nach Deutschland.
Äh ja, ja, ja, also meines Wissens gibt's zu sagen.
Okay, du weißt jetzt nicht, aber es gibt verschiedene Pipeline-Routen, die halt über längere Zeit gebaut werden, aber die sind natürlich auch.
Wie das so in der Natur der Sache ist, dafür gedacht, um das so von so einem.
Spezifischen A zu einem mehr oder weniger spezifischen B, C und D zu transportieren. Und,
Von heute auf morgen mal verlegen und irgendwo anders äh über diese Pipeline liegen. Deswegen sind diese Pipelines ja auch so so wichtig und so strategisch.
Was es halt auch gibt, das ist ja jetzt viel über Nordstream zwei diskutiert worden und das
Deutschland jetzt eben Nord Stream zwei nicht zertifiziert hat und das jetzt auf absehbare Zeit halt wahrscheinlich auch nicht in Betrieb genommen werden wird. Das liegt da halt jetzt einfach rum. Aber wie man an dem Namen Nord Stream 2 schon ganz gut feststellen kann, gibt's auch einen Nordstream.
Eins, also es ist nicht so, dass es nicht schon eine Pipeline gegeben hat. Man hat halt nur noch eine zweite dazu gebaut und über diese erste wird Gas angeliefert in Europa.
Und Europa ist abhängig von diesem Gas. Erstens unsere Wohnungen werden primär was halt primär aber im Wesentlichen.
Großen Teil mit Gas äh geheizt. Das ist einer der der der wichtigsten und Premieren-Energieträger zum Heizen, weil wir zu blöd waren in den letzten 20 Jahren hier eine Änderung.
Herbeizuführen äh und natürlich wird in der Wirtschaft auch Gas,
zum Heizen benutzt oder generell auch für Generatoren, was weiß ich, wofür äh Gas alles noch benutzt wird.
Prozesswärme und ja ähm genau und das ist das das ist das eigentliche Problem, weil,
so bei den Heizungen in den meisten Fällen kann man zur Not sich nicht auch noch,
zur Notenheizlüfter oder man zieht dann halt einen Pullover mehr an oder so, aber äh aber wenn wenn dann keine Ahnung, 20 oder 30 Prozent
deutschen Industrieproduktion auf einmal äh stillliegend. Das ist dann natürlich richtig teuer, so dass es dann.
Natürlich äh ja richtig schlimm, aber das andere Ding ist, dass es natürlich auch für für Russland ähm,
ein Problem ist, weil die können ihr Gas auch so schnell nicht woanders hin verkaufen hieß dann immer na ja gut dann verkaufen sie halt mehr an die Chinesen und dann die Asiaten.
Aber die Pipelines nach China äh sind äh auch noch nicht fertig so die die erste große.
Sondern irgendwas nicht in drei Jahren oder so im In Betrieb genommen werden, das heißt das ist jetzt auch nichts für,
kurze Zeit und im Moment die offiziellen Schätzungen lauten wohl, dass es wohl ungefähr drei Jahre brauchen äh wird,
jetzt um Deutschland mal weitgehend unabhängig von russischem Gas zu machen, wenn man da jetzt mit Hochdruck äh rangeht.
Ähm ja das tut äh aber ja kurzfristig gesagt hat Russland da auch.
Dem Gas natürlich umgekehrt äh auch äh einen richtigen Hebel jetzt jetzt in
in der Hand, also auch Russland könnte jetzt, wenn es sich umgekehrt, entscheidet, von sich aus den Gashahn abzudrehen, dann haben wir aber ein richtiges Problem.
Und die Forderungen gab's ja auch schon oder die Drohung viel mehr, dass weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, welcher Exekutive da diese Drohung ausgesprochen hat
Innenminister irgendwie so was. Ähm ja, man könnte ja jetzt mal einen Nordstream eins äh,
abschalten und die Einschätzungen da drüber, wie dramatisch das äh wäre. Ähm die,
so ein bisschen auseinander, zumal es ja jetzt auch für Russland nicht vollkommen unproblematisch ist, weil sie würden ja dann auch quasi auf ihre letzte große Geldquelle verzichten.
Etwas, was sie sich grade überhaupt nicht so richtig leisten können. Von daher ist es,
glaube ich auch an eine etwas leere Drohung, würde Nordstream eins jetzt nicht mehr bedient werden,
dann könnten die Russen sich halt überlegen so aha okay gut dann kriegt jetzt überhaupt keiner mehr Gas aber dann bleibt halt auch relativ wenig übrig von ihren Einnahmen.
Äh andererseits würde auch Nordstream eins brachliegend bedeuten, dass äh quasi noch mehr Gas durch die Ukraine geleitet werden muss, was ja wiederum bedeutet, dass auch Russland dann wiederum der Ukraine mehr für die Durchleitung bezahlen.
Also im Moment sind so.
Doch 700 Millionen im Jahr ungefähr äh zahlt äh Russland an die Ukraine für die.
Durchleitung aber das andere Ding ist dass es halt auch weil weil wir diese großen äh äh Gastanks haben, die wohl mittlerweile.
Äh ich hörte dann doch äh wieder äh ganz gut gefüllt sind, sodass wir das auch erst äh.
In einigen Monaten wirklich zu spüren äh bekämen. Also das das äh also ähm wir haben haben wohl äh noch ein paar Monate
Reserven
so oder so und dann besteht die Hoffnung, dass das bis dahin geklärt ist und wenn das bis dahin geklärt ist, könnte man dann zumindest, wenn da jetzt mehrere Monate Pumpausfall sind, hätten wir dann immer noch einen Nordstream zwei, wo man dann ein bisschen,
was man dann vielleicht vorübergehend in Betrieb nehmen könnte, um dann sagen, ähm hm ja.
Schwierig werden.
Alle Mitarbeiter entlassen worden, also.
Ja ja ja. Ich war übrigens mal zufällig in dem in dem Haus, wo die sitzen in in dem Zug in der Schweiz, habe äh ja irgendwie ein schönes Foto vom Türschild gemacht.
Was hast du denn da gemacht? Erzählst nicht. Ähm.
Ja, ich meine, die Einschätzung dadrüber, wie viel man das Schlagwort ist natürlich so, oh, wir finanzieren den Krieg mit, ne? Ja, okay, gut, klar, indirekt sicherlich, äh, tun wir das, ne? Und wenn man halt jetzt generell Russland.
Über Sanktionen schaden möchte, um sie,
zum Einlenken zu bewegen ist natürlich jede Zahlung Quatsch. Andererseits ist das, was sie jetzt über das Gas einnehmen.
Umschlagsrechnung gehört so, dass es dann irgendwie auch so eher in der Größenordnung von vier Dollar äh pro.
Russischen Bewohner pro Jahr. Das macht's jetzt irgendwie auch nicht so äh wett zumal ja auch die Kosten für alles.
Enorm ansteigen gerade.
Und man könnt's natürlich auch umdrehen und sagen, okay und Russland äh hilft jetzt mit seinem Gas, der
deutschen Rüstungs
Industriewaffen zu bauen, die dann in der Ukraine oder gegen Russland eingesetzt werden. Ja, das funktioniert also so ein bisschen in in in beide Richtungen dieser dieser Vorwurf äh der anderen Seite äh jetzt irgendwie unter die
unter die Arme äh zugreifen oder sie in Konflikt zu unterstützen und ähm ja.
Muss man sehen die äh Biogas
Branche hat wohl auch schon gesagt, na ja Leute, wenn ihr mal eure Verordnungen ein bisschen abspecken würdet und da die Deckelung äh aufheben würdet, dann könnten wir relativ kurzer Zeit
äh Biogas liefern, was irgendwie fünf Prozent dieses Gasvolumens übernehmen könnte.
Das war halt bisher nicht so richtig profitabel, aber einen anderen Betracht steigender Preise und eben dieser ganzen potenziellen Nebenkosten wie totale Zerstörung eines Landes. Ähm
Könnte das ja vielleicht auch eine gute Investition sein. Ich habe eh so den Eindruck, dass das jetzt relativ schnell vorangehen wird mit dem.
Alternativen Energieausbau, aber das haben wir ja letztes Mal im Prinzip auch schon angesprochen, von daher können wir, glaube ich, hier zum nächsten Aspekt übergehen.
Ja, genau, aber kann man trotzdem noch erwähnen, dass natürlich
es auch positive Auswirkungen gibt der ganzen Krise, äh nämlich dass äh regenerative Energien jetzt
wettbewerbsfähiger geworden sind äh dadurch und dass wahrscheinlich jetzt auch die Nachfrage, weil sie nicht nach Elektroautos wahrscheinlich in die Höhe gehen wird äh und.
Und,
und und dass das Ganze jetzt äh wahrscheinlich die die Energie äh Wende deutlich beschleunigen äh wird. Das das Ganze.
Aber vielleicht auch noch ein weiterer Punkt zur zur Situation äh in den in den USA hm
wie eigentlich die russische Industrie so aufgestellt ist und äh die die.
These oder in dem Artikel war okay, die ganzen Oligarchen haben halt äh so die ganze
Extraktionswirtschaft mehr oder weniger unter sich. Also äh Rohstoffförderung, äh Energieförderung und so. Alles Sachen, die.
Eher so äh ja einfach sind, die jetzt sagen nicht nicht jetzt äh hyperkomplex sind äh technologisch und für die komplexe Technologie, die kommt dann eben
aus dem aus dem Ausland und da war dann auch so schön in dem am Ende glaube ich ein.
Twitters äh oder nicht Twitter, sondern irgendein anderes irgendeinen Twitter-Clohn, auf dem das ist äh einen einen Sweat, wo es darum geht,
dass halt Technologieunternehmer äh in Russland eher so in der Hackordnung.
Dann eher unten rangieren. Ja, das sind, weil weil so Technologien äh.
Das ist halt hochtechnologie, das ist kompliziert und
Ähm ja äh damit wollen die sich eigentlich nicht nicht abgeben und haben natürlich auch mitgekriegt, äh
wenn du da nicht zum Inner Circle gehörst, dann äh wird dir entweder auch, äh wenn's wenn's halt den den
oberen du nicht passt, dann nehmen die dir einfach die Firma ab. Ähm
somit sagen dann okay du hast jetzt keine Steuern bezahlt und äh stecken dich in den Knast und äh nehmen dir die Firma ab. Hm,
bei den jetzt Hochtechnologiefirmen ja waren dann auch so so so Dinge, dass die dann gesagt haben speziell jetzt bei bei so Fördertechnologie, also Kohle Fördermaschinen, wo dann.
Die einen äh eine russische Firma ganz ganz gut war und die haben dem halt so viel Stress gemacht, dass er,
dann angefangen hat seine Maschinen die Maschinen zur Reparatur.
Nach Tschechien zu schicken. So
ähm und zur Wartung. Was eigentlich eigentlich ziemlicher Quatsch ist, weil das sind sind riesige Apparate und warum sollte man die jetzt ausgerechnet in
Tschechien warten oder überholen lassen und Vermutung war aber, dass er das Wirklichkeit gemacht hat, um eine Produktion in Tschechien
aufzubauen, um quasi äh ja aus diesem Russland rauszukommen, wo sie ihm dann Vorwürfe gemacht haben.
Dass seine Maschinen zu teuer sind und ihn gezwungen haben, die Maschinen billiger zu verkaufen. So äh aber gleichzeitig durch den Rubelverfall äh seine ganzen ja,
seine Importe extrem teurer geworden sind ähm.
Und deswegen ist es wohl ein Problem, weil die generell so mit mit ihrer, sage mal, veredelnden Hochtechnologie,
Industrie äh umgehen, dass Russland vor allem nach wie vor Rohstoffe produziert und,
eigentlich alles was so ein bisschen mehr technologisch ist oder ein Großteil davon aus dem Westen bezieht und ich selbst,
Sowas wie jetzt Methologie. Ich habe mich dann gefragt, als ich gehört habe.
Dass äh Großteil der äh Metalle jetzt für die Raketen, die da verschossen werden, von Deutschland geliefert wurde. Die haben mich gefragt, mein Gott, können jetzt in Russland nicht mehr irgendwie vernünftige Bleche
äh machen. Das das das konnten ihm mal alle alles, aber nee, das ist dann halt wohl ein ein Thema, das jetzt für die Uli Garrchen zu kompliziert ist äh und
ja
Und eben diese ja diese mehr ich sage mal intelligenten Leute oder Wissenschaftler halt äh sich sich dann eher lieber abgesetzt haben oder geguckt haben, dass sie dann lieber die Sachen
im Ausland äh produzieren
lassen und deswegen wird das wahrscheinlich auch äh äh an ganz vielen Ecken und Enden jetzt Probleme geben in in in Russland, weil die eigene Technologie
Industrie, von den Oligarchen mit Füßen getreten wurde. So könnte man das äh vielleicht äh vereinfacht ausdrücken.
Ja. Gut ähm schon mal vielleicht mal.
Auf die Ukraine und wie da die die Situation äh eigentlich äh ist.
Haben wir jetzt noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen so richtig. Äh schwer einzuschätzen. Also.
Tatsache ist, die Russen sind noch nie weg. Die es gibt zwar nicht so viel Vormarsch-Bewegung, es gibt sehr unterschiedliche.
Der Lage, was da jetzt grade wirklich passiert während so im Süden ähm die russische Armee sehr wohl Boden hat gut machen können, war das im Norden nicht so der Fall.
Auch nicht unbedingt gute Nachrichten sein müssen, denn das bedeutet auf der anderen Seite, dass sie unter Umständen sich einfach erstmal tiefer eingegraben haben und äh Nachschub organisiert haben und sozusagen das, was sie bisher haben, mehr mehr sichern.
Kann sein, also es ist eine reine äh äh Vermutung. Tatsache ist, dass die Bodengewinne ähm überschaubar geblieben sind, sprich die Ukrainer zumindest vor Kiew weitgehend ähm.
Ihren ja den Vormarsch soweit erstmal gestoppt haben.
Was nicht heißt, dass es jetzt gar keinen gibt und auch kleine Fortschritte helfen, den Russen, weil ihr Ziel natürlich ist irgendwie Kiew äh zum Zinkeln oder zumindest die Korridore so kontrollierbar zu machen, dass dass einfach Kiew ausgetrocknet wird.
Ja und äh wohl aus dem.
Osten äh werden wohl jetzt größere Mengen auch einfach an Panzern äh Panzerkolonnen herangeführt, also
das äh Großteil der der wohl der schweren Waffen also Panzer und Artillerie sind wohl noch gar nicht äh wirklich an der Front
angekommen oder noch nicht noch nicht an der Front im im Einsatz. Äh auf der anderen Seite äh so.
Die Meldung, dass jetzt praktisch fast 100 Prozent der Truppen, die,
Russland um die Ukraine herum versammelt hatte jetzt auch im Einsatz sind. So also die bewegen sich jetzt alle.
Und äh was auch ganz schön rauskam, ist dass äh Russland bei Verlegungen von Truppen,
vor allem auf das Eisenbahnnetz äh,
setzt so. Die die werden also ja vor allem mit der Eisenbahn äh transportiert und äh müssen dann natürlich jetzt irgendwann.
Ja dann von der Eisenbahn runter in Russland und müssen dann dann selber äh weiterfahren und,
Dabei hat sich dann aber eben rausgestellt, dass wohl viel von dem Gerät auch nicht so richtig toll gewartet äh war. Insbesondere äh mehrfach erwähnt, dass halt,
man, wenn Fahrzeuge irgendwo draußen
rumstehen, dass man die dann schon wenigstens einmal im Monat irgendwie ein bisschen bewegen muss und auch die ja, mal die Reifen so ähm
Ähm mal eine eine andere Stelle belastet wird und insbesondere
auch ähm ja mal die einen und mal die anderen Reifen wohl mehr in die Sonne äh packen und äh das ist wohl nicht passiert, sodass halt jetzt auch ohne Ende
Jetzt beim beim Vormarsch äh ihnen die äh Reifen äh zerfallen sind, weil die nicht nicht.
Hat mir das hier letzte Mal schon angesprochen, den Aspe.
Weiß ich nicht aber gut so aber da sind halt noch mehr und mehr Bilder jetzt zum Vorschein gekommen plus
was man eben auch sieht ist, dass sie jetzt auch ähm,
gerade vor allem eine Schwäche bei äh Transport,
Fahrzeugen haben, dass sie zu wenig Tankfahrzeuge haben. Es ist auch eine ganze Menge zerstört worden und mittlerweile finden sich auf den Zügen so vor allem ja äh zivile äh Tank
Fahrzeuge und Transporter und Busse und so und mit denen wird's natürlich nicht einfacher, da durch den Matsch
äh durch durchzukommen oder oder äh überhaupt. Das heißt, es gibt eben tatsächlich auch viele Anzeichen dafür, dass einfach äh Material äh tatsächlich knapp,
äh wird und insbesondere eben so rollendes,
Material und äh zudem ja äh haben haben die Ukrainer eben auch äh die.
Zug äh Verbindungen äh wohl so zerstört, dass die Russen jetzt das ukrainische Eisenbahnnetz nicht nutzen können, um um dort Dinge zu transportieren oder weiter zu transportieren.
Nee, das ist ganz klar, weil das ist ja die einfachste Möglichkeit, sie aufzuhalten, es sie einfach auf die Straßen zu zwingen. Damit können sie nur über ganz dünne Korridore kommen, müssen sich die mühsam freikämpfen und das ist ja auch der Hauptgrund, warum es überhaupt bisher so langsam läuft.
Ja und der Verschleiß ist natürlich irre, also mit so einem Panzer ist jetzt nicht dafür gedacht. So damit zu viel rumzufahren.
Ja und wenn Sie aus dem Osten kommen, um bis nach Kiew vorzudringen,
das sind schon äh erhebliche Strecken. Ne also wenn man mal äh sich das anschaut, wenn jetzt ähm an der russischen Grenze am nächsten Bereich.
Ich muss das mal hier kurz mal aus. Kiew, Zentrum, wozu haben wir äh Google Earth,
Also wenn die quasi das erste Mal den Zug äh verlassen, dann sind es so, na ja, Luftlinie sechshundert Kilometer, also Fahrstrecke über Straßen,
Tendenziell eher ein Tausender. Bisschen äh kürzer ist es, wenn sie jetzt über die
Krim kommen, dann sind's nur irgendwie fünfhunderteinundvierzig Kilometer, aber das setzt halt auch voraus, dass sie da irgendwie grade äh durchschießen können. Was halt derzeit nicht der Fall ist, weil sie einfach an allen Stellen
aufgehalten werden. Ja, das soll jetzt gar nicht.
So rüberkommen, dass man das alles auf die leichte Schulter nehmen muss. Also die Probleme sind so groß, dass.
Auch so eine Riesenarmee ihren Vorteil nicht ausspielen kann. Es ist sehr schwierig einzuschätzen.
Wohin das mündet. Ja, das kann heiß einerseits alles.
Bricht irgendwie zusammen. Das kommt einfach nicht genug Gerät an. Allein schon deshalb, weil
die Ukraineische Armee äh es relativ einfach hat diese hm diesen Vorstoß immer wieder unter Kontrolle zu halten, weil letzten Endes brauchen sie nur das schwächste Glied anzugreifen, nämlich die Tankwagen.
Wenn es ihm gelingt, die Tankwagen, die kaum geschützt sind, in irgendeiner Form mit einer Rakete zu stoppen, stoppen sie damit automatisch auch an Panzer, weil den geht einfach der Sprit aus.
Können die nicht mehr fahren. So und dann stehen die da halt rum und dann dann dann,
ja diesen schönen äh Mem-Account von von den äh Ukrainern, wo die ganze Zeit so lustige Internetmeme zum Krieg gepostet werden.
Ein bisschen absurd so, ne, aber die stellen halt auch schon fest, dass mittlerweile die äh ukrainischen Bauern die größte Militärmacht in Europa darstellen, so viele Panzer, wie die schon eingesammelt haben. Ähm
ja
Ja ja, das ist schon eine Menge.
Äh man ich meine man muss natürlich immer vorsichtig sein so vor allem in in in Kriegszeiten, dass man jetzt nicht zu viel der Propaganda auf äh sitzt
und nicht jetzt zuviel auch, weil man sich das einfach nur wünscht, dass es äh wahr ist äh so, deswegen muss muss es,
noch lange nicht wahr sein, äh weshalb,
da auch immer eher ähm ja äh erstmal grundsätzlich skeptisch bin und versuche natürlich,
aus möglichst vielen,
verschiedenen Quellen die Dinge zusammenzuführen und zu gucken passt das jetzt zusammen, passt das jetzt nicht zusammen?
Und ähm da ist aber jetzt tatsächlich mein Eindruck ähm,
dass äh ja die Schwierigkeiten wirklich real äh sind. Dass das also jetzt sehen Sie's nicht, dass dann jetzt nicht äh der der Wunsch der der Vater der Dinge,
ist äh sondern äh dass ähm ja das russische Militär erhebliche Probleme hat und.
Insbesondere sind wir aber jetzt an einem Punkt angekommen. Ich sagte ja vorhin, die gesamten russischen Kräfte äh sind jetzt im Einsatz und im Einsatz bedeutet, sie verschleißen.
So durch rumfahren, durch Rumstehen und durch beschossen äh werden und äh ja äh das heißt
Da kommt jetzt
erstmal wohl auch so schnell nicht mehr so viel nach. Wobei klar, die Russen ziehen jetzt aus allen Landesteilen äh wohl auch nochmal weitere Kräfte nach und versuchen
da zu verstärken, wie gesagt vor allen Dingen ähm so Transportfahrzeuge und Kapazität und LKWs und und Busse und so.
Das heißt, hm.
Das tendenziell jetzt die russische Armee ähm von Tag zu Tag eher,
schwächer äh wird. So also die die Zahl der der Waffen äh abnimmt, der der Treibstoff knapper wird, die Munition knapper wird. Äh während,
Auf der anderen Seite die Ukraine.
Jetzt von Tag zu Tag eher stärker wird und zwar aus folgenden Gründen. Ich hatte ja auch,
letzten Sendung schon mal, dass das das Thema Zahlen aufgemacht. Wie wir wie viel steht sich denn jetzt gegenüber? Wer steht sich denn der jetzt eigentlich gerade gegenüber? Und.
Habe mich dann gefragt, also ja es war ja wohl dann mittlerweile 250.000 ukrainische Soldaten, die wohl mittlerweile aktiv waren.
Aber es wurde halt immer die Zahl von 900.000 Reservisten.
Genannt. Und ich habe mich gefragt, okay was ist jetzt wo sind jetzt diese 900.000 Reservisten? Und was ist mit den anderen sieben Millionen ähm
an Männern im im äh wehrfähigen Alter beziehungsweise fit for Military Service so. Wo sind denn die? Ja wo tauchen die denn
auf jetzt zahlenmäßig und.
Was ich jetzt so rausstellt ist, na ja, es dauert halt schon etwas länger, die zu mobilisieren. Hm.
Und äh was aber eben jetzt seit Kriegsausbruch natürlich mit Hochdruck passiert. Das heißt.
Die ukrainische Armee.
Jetzt täglich einen ständigen Zulauf an Kräften, der so schnell auch nicht versiegen wird, äh sondern die können jetzt äh sie ukrainische Armee kann im Prinzip,
jetzt.
Sag mal ein Jahr lang äh täglich äh aufbauen bis sie eine Stärke von mehreren Millionen erreicht hat und,
Sagen, naja gut, das fehlt jetzt an Material und so an an an schweren Waffen. Aber da ist dann natürlich jetzt der der Westen äh wiederum da, beziehungsweise die NATO.
Mit ihren 40.0000 Milliarden Bruttoinlandsprodukt und 950 Millionen Einwohnern, die da jetzt Material reinschieben und ähm es auch.
Schwer zu sagen, welchen Umfang äh das jetzt hat, weil ähm da wird halt nicht alles an die große Glocke gehängt,
Ähm äh.
Aber eine eine Menge äh kommt halt durch und ich gehe aber davon aus, äh zumindest gibt's da wirklich viele Anzeichen, dass das grade jetzt,
wirklich auf Hochtouren läuft und dass da äh auch Material und Waffen in einem Umfang geliefert wird, äh der wesentlich größer ist als das, was man jetzt in den Medien äh zu sehen.
Bekommt. So mit anderen Worten hm das Kräfteverhältnis beginnt sich jetzt langsam zu verschieben. Es wird jetzt nicht morgen äh,
jetzt den die die Wände bringen, aber wenn wir jetzt Wochen oder ein paar Monate äh noch noch voraus äh schauen, dann wird es irgendwann äh wirklich zum Kipp,
Punkt com beziehungsweise als erstes und das sieht so aus, als wären wir da nicht mehr weit von entfernt.
Wird das Ganze erstmal zum Stillstand kommen, also wird es keinen Bewegungskrieg mehr werden für die Russen, sondern mehr in so eine Art Stellungskrieg.
Äh aus äharten und äh sie werden sich irgendwie weder vor noch noch zurückbewegen können und wenn natürlich dann Panzern, Sprit und Munition ausgeht, äh
nützt dir deine Übermacht jetzt auch nicht mehr nicht mehr so viel
und dann äh scheint es auch so zu sein, was ich auch irre fand. Ich habe mich mal gefragt, äh wieso stehen denn da völlig funktionstüchtige Panzer am Rand rum, diese diese Bilder, wo dann ähm.
Ja äh auch einige Ukrainer so äh Joy Rights mit Panzern äh äh vorgenommen haben und stellt sich raus, die mussten halt nur ein bisschen Sprit reinkippen.
Und äh dann äh ja war alles alles gut. Das heißt äh langfristig die Russen teilweise nicht mal die Mühe gemacht haben jetzt
Panzer äh dann einfach aufzutanken, sondern die Lieber haben stehen lassen. Ja äh,
Was äh natürlich auch äh schon mal drauf hindeutet, dass es dort um die um die Disziplin in in der russischen Armee nicht so besonders gut bestellt ist.
Ich hörte sogar davon, dass sie teilweise äh auch sich einfach ein Loch in Tank reingehauen haben, um irgendwie einen Grund zu haben, zu flüchten.
Das höre ich auch, dass das teilweise sozusagen russische Soldaten ihr eigenes Equipment sabotieren, um äh nicht ähm äh weiter.
Zu müssen. Ja äh man weiß natürlich nicht, das sind,
wie verbreitet das Ganze ist, aber selbst, dass solche Einzelfälle überhaupt auftreten äh ist natürlich schon.
Ein Problem. Also wenn was weiß ich jetzt bei bei westlichen Armeen, wenn die irgendwo Equipment
zurücklassen oder zurückgelassen haben.
Wurde das entweder vor Ort in die Luft gesprengt, aber meistens wurde dann so ein so ein Luftschlag äh ähm gerufen, wo man dann halt das das eigene liegengebliebene Fahrzeug bombardiert hat, damit,
dass Equipment bloß nicht in fremde Hände fällt, aber sowas, ich meine, da da können die Russen jetzt überhaupt gar nicht dran denken, sagen so äh mit ihrem Material dann dann umzugehen gerade offenbar.
Kommen wir dann auch gleich nochmal glaube ich dazu, wenn die Frage debattieren, was Europa NATO jetzt eigentlich,
tun sollte. Vielleicht sollte man an der Stelle aber auch nochmal klar machen, dass natürlich die humanitäre Situation sich in den Kriegsgebieten extrem verschlechtert hat, ne. Einerseits durch,
unmittelbaren Beschuss, Wohngebäude werden einfach äh großflächig bombardiert mit Raketen et cetera alles aus der Ferne, alles maximal brutal. Krankenhäuser
Also die russische Armee hat wirklich
relativ wenig äh bis gar keine Skrupel jetzt gilt einfach nur noch so dieses was wir können euch nicht in drei Tagen Hobs nehmen, da dann da hauen wir jetzt einfach so lange drauf bis hier alles platt ist und dann werdet ihr schon irgendwann aufgeben.
Auch wenn wir danach keinen Plan haben, wie wir dieses Land überhaupt halten können und das ist eigentlich auch mittlerweile vollkommen ausgeschlossen ist, dass in irgendeiner Form dieses Land.
Gewonnen werden kann. Ja also es ist ja vollkommen.
Unvorstellbar. Also selbst wenn jetzt Selinsky sagen würde so oh ja nee genug gekämpft, wir geben jetzt auf. Ihr habt ja äh den Schlüssel ähm ja oder sie in umbringen würden.
Russland hätte niemals die Möglichkeit in irgendeiner Form das Land irgendwie,
unter Kontrolle zu bekommen.
Und in Griff zu kriegen und in Griff zu behalten, ohne nicht permanent von einem permanenten Guerillakrieg zermürbt zu werden. Das ist quasi die Ukraine ist in der Hinsicht eigentlich auch schon wieder so ein Afghanistan.
Ja als ob sie wirklich aus diesem Ganzen nichts gelernt haben. Aber die Humanitäre Lage ist natürlich schwierig. Und dann gibt's,
speziell dieses Problem, dass natürlich einzelne Städte jetzt auch eingeschlossen sind, also zum Beispiel Mariopol. Das ist äh der Ort, der im Prinzip genau zwischen den beiden Frontlinien,
liegt die aus dem Osten kommen, aus dem Donezk äh Gebiet und dem Angriff über die Krim,
da sind halt jetzt quasi Lücken auch äh geschlossen worden, sprich Russland hat jetzt von der Krim am ähm.
Wie heißt dieser obere Teil über dem Schwarzen Meer? Wie nennt man das? Also was rechts neben der Krim ist.
Dieses äh Gebiet Asovsches Meer heißt das.
Also an der an der Küstenlinie des Asofischen Meers, da haben sie sozusagen die Verbindung jetzt geschlossen von der Krim, äh Russland, also untenrum ist es sozusagen ja eh schon mit der Übernahme der Krim die Verbindung zu Russland hergestellt worden. Jetzt haben sie eben diese Verbindung auch.
Obenrum und greifen quasi da auf breiter Front äh an.
Und Mario Pohl ist halt eingeschlossen und äh da ist Noir Tour Hight und jetzt wird natürlich dann äh die Situation in den Städten immer äh krasser,
Energieversorgung, durfte an manchen Stellen zusammengebrochen sein, kein Wasser et cetera, kein Essen. Also irgendwann ist es halt auch ein Ele.
Natürlich auch krass ist, ist
Das äh grade auch von ukrainischer Seite jetzt oft erwähnt wird, das ist natürlich äh das letzte Mal, dass halt manche Städte so in Schutt und Asche gelegt worden sind, war
als die deutsche Wehrmacht äh,
dort äh vorbeigekommen ist. Ja und das das äh bringt da jetzt auch bei ganz vielen Leuten
ja diese Erinnerungen äh äh zurück oder äh ja lästern Vergleiche zu was auch Irrsinn ist, ist das Marieopol.
Halt auch immer noch nicht eingenommen ist, ja. Es ist halt äh ja, äh klar, äh die.
Großen Kämpfen auch nicht nicht wirklich mit jetzt,
voller Brutalität, also die äh ähm.
Halten sich halt schon natürlich noch ein bisschen zurück, weil am Ende wollen sie natürlich auch äh
Jahr zumindest in den Gegnern wahrscheinlich um Mario Pohl äh wollen sie halt äh ja das Ganze dann auch noch vielleicht nutzen äh hinterher mal mal wieder Plus,
dass natürlich das auch ähm ein Problem ist ähm wenn sie jetzt zu brutal,
Vorgehen ähm das gibt nicht nur.
Unschöne Bilder, wobei es gibt halt schon eine ganze Menge unschöne äh Bilder, aber äh man muss.
Auch konstatieren.
Dass jetzt die Zahl der Todesopfer sich im Vergleich zu früheren Konflikten oder wenn sie jetzt ich sage mal wirklich voll aufdrehen äh würden so äh wie das damals die deutsche Wehrmacht
äh gemacht hat. Äh mein gut, damals waren Kriege wohl auch offensichtlich doch noch eine Nummer,
blutiger. Da sind glaube ich in Mariopol äh an einem Tag ähm
00.000 Menschen getötet worden oder nach der Belagerung waren halt ja äh hunderttausend Tod innerhalb von weniger wenigen Tagen.
Und obwohl die Opfer der Zivilbevölkerung äh natürlich jeder Einzelne äh so ist, ist natürlich schrecklich. Ähm.
Sind die Zahlen jetzt vergleichsweise äh äh halten sich da noch noch in Grenzen. Also äh ja das ist jetzt nicht so das Schlachten von Hunderttausenden oder von Millionen.
Aber das kann natürlich noch werden, so das kann natürlich alles noch kommen.
Ja gut, ich meine, die Nazis äh tendieren ja dann auch eher dazu, einfach Massenmorde zu äh begehen und sich sozusagen der der Probleme dann dauerhaft zu äh,
entledigen. Die Russen scheint es hier zunächst einmal vor allem um Schock and Ohr zu äh gehen und irgendwie möglichst viel
so rüberzukommen als wären sie gnadenlos, aber na ja, egal. Das kann man jetzt im Einzelnen nicht bewirken. Ich will halt nur sagen, die humanitäre Situation ist schwierig.
Diese ganze Diskussion um Fluchtkorridore ist halt auch krass nicht wahr. Also da gab's dann halt welche, dann waren die aber vermint und die Leute wurden trotzdem beschossen.
Und solche Angebote äh an die Ukraine wie ja, kein Problem äh ihr könnt auch die Leute hier einfach alle nach Russland oder nach Weißrussland kommen lassen.
Mhm. Mhm super.
Das ist auch eine ganz tolle Idee. Also erstmal will da natürlich da niemand hinfliehen.
Aber davon ganz abgesehen würde sich halt die Ukraine auf so etwas einlassen, dann würde das ja im Prinzip bedeuten,
Ach ja, klar, wir machen jetzt hier mal Waffenstillstand für diesen Bereich,
mit direkten Verbindungen zu eurem Land. Ja, das heißt dann würden die Flüchtlinge in die eine Richtung fahren und ihnen würden die ganze Zeit die Panzer entgegenkommen. Die sagen ja super, alles klar.
Danke, das brauchten wir grade mal.
Nee nee das ist das ist natürlich äh ja äh wirklich äh zynisch. Wobei noch äh ja also wie
Weil ich bin dann äh.
Sagen Ihnen die sagen Ihnen die Anfänge der Kriegsführung aber äh so ein bisschen dann auch zum äh alten,
Rom äh äh noch und nochmal gegangen und habe dann bisschen Vergleiche ähm ähm angestellt so.
Gut was Russland
bis hier führt, ist ähm ein Eroberungskrieg oder das das war zumindest das das Ziel halt ja
äh zu erobern und unter den Römern äh war das so, wenn,
dort jemand einen Eroberungskrieg führen wollte, dann war das gab's dafür so äh spezielle Franchises ähm so da wurde dann Projektplan äh gemacht für die für die Investoren. Da wird dann geguckt
okay, wenn wir da jetzt reingehen, dann äh bringen wir da moderne Technologie äh rein, verbessern äh die Erträge beim beim beim Ackerbau und bauen Straßen und machen da eine richtige Verwaltung und
steigern dann die Produktivität des Landes um weiß nicht 2030 Prozent und dann äh können wir sagen daraus dann den,
Krieg finanzieren beziehungsweise den Investoren dann den entsprechenden Return äh zahlen und und alles läuft. So das war sozusagen die die eine Sorte.
Von Krieg, wo man dann natürlich,
eher nicht die ganzen Leute umbringen und alles in Schutt und Asche legen will. Aber dann gab's halt noch die zweite Sorte, also was nicht Eroberungskrieg war, sondern was entweder.
Ja so ein so ein.
Bestrafungs äh äh Krieg äh war oder Abwehrkrieg äh so wo man dann einfach nur vor allen Dingen Feinde vernichten wollte.
Und äh ja das das waren dann äh ganz klar ja diese Bestrafungs oder Vernichtungskriege, wo äh man einer der schlimmsten Wahrheit in Israel
wo nachdem dann dort die Juden irgendwie das dritte Mal äh Aufstand gemacht haben wirklich
alles komplett in Schutt und Asche gelegt wurde und jeder jeden, den man finden konnte, der war
wurde umgebracht. Also das war halt ganz klar ein Krieg mit äh der der Absicht äh Genozid äh zu begehen, also ist wirklich so ein Bestrafungs und Vernichtungskrieg.
Zusammenhang mit der Ukraine besteht natürlich jetzt die Befürchtung, dass wenn jetzt
absehbar ist, dass äh Eroberungskrieg nicht möglich ist oder nicht funktioniert, dass dann äh jetzt das Ganze mehr in eine Art Bestrafungs- und Vernichtungs äh Krieg äh um
schlägt äh der sich dann auch direkt gegen die Bevölkerung äh äh richtet und dann mit
schen Säuberungen und Vertreibung und so verbunden ist. Also mal eine sagen, alles sehr, sehr viel unappetitlicher wird.
Ja den Eindruck macht es auch schon.
Und dann ja ich weiß nicht ob wir jetzt schon bei dem Thema sind aber es ist.
Ich wollte vielleicht kurz diese humanitäre Situation mal kurz abschließen. Es gibt ja auch noch einen Teil, der sich außerhalb äh der Ukraine abspielt. Wir haben jetzt eine riesige Flüchtlingsbewegung nach äh Polen.
Deutschland und ähm Rumänien, Ungarn, also alle nahe gelegenen und auch weitergelegenen europäischen Länder, wo die Aufnahmebereitschaft.
Teilweise relativ hoch ist, Klammer auf Polen, Deutschland, Klammer zu oder auch irgendwie Länder sich komplett sperren.
Wer sich hier so grade so richtig zum Affen macht, sind natürlich die Briten.
Ah, okay.
Natürlich überhaupt nicht eingebunden sind in die EU-Disziplin, weil sie ja sich äh von Russen haben aus der EU rausnehmen lassen.
Und ähm die haben's also jetzt schon geschafft sage und schreibe 50 Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen.
Weil der Rest hängt irgendwie in Calais und äh muss irgendwie Formulare ausfüllen. Also es ist wirklich äh.
Ja, während in der EU glaube ich man relativ schnell beschlossen hat, dass die Leute einfach erstmal drei Jahre Aufenthaltsrecht haben und äh ja.
Arbeiten dürfen und alles, das volle Programm, genau.
Das hätte man sich bei anderen Krisen auch schon äh gewünscht. Umso besser, dass es jetzt auch stattgefunden hat. Ähm,
rechtlich weiß ich noch nicht, ob das schon alles äh klar ist. Es gibt sicherlich noch ein paar Unklarheiten, aber umso klarer das gefasst wird, umso besser, umso besser kann man da halt auch helfen, ne und gerade was weiß ich. Wenn jetzt jemand so eine Wohnung vermieten will, dann willst du ja irgendwie auch wissen, woran du da bist. So, ne.
Ja und ähm,
ist sicherlich auch für Europa jetzt eine Riesenaufgabe, dessen Herr zu werden. Die Schätzungen gehen halt bis zu 10 Millionen Leute, die irgendwie das Land verlassen von den 40 Millionen, also ungefähr ein Viertel.
Das hat wohl so noch nicht stattgefunden, aber über eine Million oder zwei, ich glaube bei zwei Millionen ist man schon.
Wir müssten irgendwo in der Gegend bei zwei Millionen sein mittlerweile, ja.
So genau weiß es wahrscheinlich auch keiner.
Ja äh vielleicht kurz was zur Infrastruktur noch in äh in der Ukraine, da ist ja auch viel drüber berichtet worden. Die Russen haben sich jetzt schon äh Tschernobyl vereinnahmt. Das ist ein bisschen unklar, was sie dort machen. Ist angeblich
vom Stromnetz entkoppelt, was natürlich ein Problem ist, weil dort Strom auch gebraucht wird, um diese ganzen Einfriedungsmaßnahmen dieses alten äh Reaktorunglücksortes ähm betreiben zu können.
Plus. Es gab ja da auch noch mehrere Reaktorblöcke, die ja dann noch jahrelang in Betrieb waren und das Ganze dient eben auch als Zwischenlager für äh abgebrannte Brennstäbe. Dieser ähm,
Ja äh Kraftwerksblöcke, das heißt, das ist,
Das ist eher das Ding. Habe ich jetzt gelesen seit zwei Sachen. Einmal die Kühlung der abgebrannten Brennstäbe, aber die sind mittlerweile schon so weit ab,
äh und die Wassermengen sind so groß, dass da wohl jetzt nicht die Gefahr besteht, wie in Fukushima, wo
äh dann als die Kühlung ausgefallen sind und die Brennstäbe noch eher frisch waren. Dann äh plötzlich dort auch die die Zwischenlager ähm sich sich äh über Hitz.
Äh haben und ähm ja, dass es jetzt hier nicht zu erwarten, aber ich hörte.
Aber das äh waren es auch Probleme mit der Belüftung äh gibt und mit der Luftfeuchtigkeits äh Kontrolle und.
Mit der ganzen Überwachung, äh sodass halt jetzt dieser ultrateure Sark neue Sarkophag, der da jetzt gebaut wurde, äh möglicherweise Schäden äh nehmen kann, wenn das nicht äh
bald äh gefixt wird. So aber unmittelbare Gefahr so jetzt wohl nicht nicht bestehen, dass da irgendwie Radioaktivität
austritt oder sich das jetzt sofort überhitzt, aber es ist natürlich unschön, weil wir auch das ganze Monitoring-Equipment
gerade nicht nicht funktioniert und ja ist nicht schön.
Trotzdem die Russen scheinen auf jeden Fall drauf äh auszusahen, die viel Kernkraftwerke in irgendeiner Form einzunehmen, mutmaßlich, um sozusagen die Energieversorgung der Ukraine damit in den Griff zu bekommen.
Sie sind im Süden auf das äh Kernkraftwerk.
Vorgestoßen, da gab's ja diesen Vorfall, dass sie irgendwie so einen Nachbar, so ein so ein so ein so ein ähm.
Gebäude in Brand geschossen haben, also nicht das eigentliche Kraftwerk an sich. Da gab's ja schon ein bisschen Aufregung.
Unklare Situation, zweites ist das sogenannte Kernkraftwerk Südukraine. Auch da sind sie schon vorgestoßen mit einem Trupp. Da gibt's äh Kämpfe ähm.
Und dann natürlich der Raum äh Tschernobyl und dann gibt's auch noch einen anderen Standort, den ich jetzt äh nicht aufm Zeiger habe, aber das ist auf jeden Fall so ein Thema und damit stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, wie sieht's denn überhaupt
jetzt sozusagen um die ähm Energieversorgung in der Ukraine aus, wenn äh die Russen halt dann das Netz äh entsprechend sabotieren.
Teilweise sind's ja auch selber davon abhängig. Also es ist für sie für sie ja jetzt sagen wir mal nicht so, dass es darum geht, ja, schalte mal alles ab. Ja, dann.
Haben sie ja auch keine Energie mehr im Zweifelsfall. Das wollen sie auch nicht.
Also würde ich jetzt mal vermuten zumindest, ja. Äh
auch so Kernkraftwerke zusammenschießen, ist auch irgendwie nicht so eine richtig geile Idee. Was ich äh auch noch mitbekommen habe, ist, dass es durchaus auch Überlegungen äh vielleicht auch schon Aktivitäten gibt, da an den Stellen, wo es möglich ist, die Ukraine vielleicht ans EU-Netz anzuschließen in Rumänien oder so.
Äh ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt auf die Schnelle äh funktionieren sollte. Keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt ist mit äh ob's da irgendwelche auch Bridges äh äh gibt schon, äh die halt Energiefluss äh äh,
erlauben, ob's da irgendeine Kupplung äh schon schon gibt, äh aber.
Also es gab auf jeden Fall die Anfrage der Ukrainer das zu tun.
Und ich vermute mal, das dürfte auch äh nur erfolgen, wenn es auch eine gewisse hm Realisierungschance hat, welcher Aufwand dafür zu machen ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe hier nur so eine Meldung von der.
European der Socialation for the Cooperation of Transition System Operators, TSO for electricity, die das sozusagen berichtet haben. Das ist äh am 27. Februar diese Anfrage gab.
Ähm ja jetzt sind wir hier eigentlich bei dem Punkt.
Was sollte Europa jetzt eigentlich tun? Und wozu sind wir denn jetzt? Was ist denn jetzt geboten? Die Diskussionen fliegen hin und her.
Mir ist in dem Zusammenhang dann aufgefallen ähm was ist denn eigentlich unser Ziel?
So, weil es wurde halt viel darüber spekuliert. Ja, okay, was ist Putins Ziel oder Russlands Ziel und was ist irgendwie sein Endgame fiel mir ein, okay, was ist denn jetzt aber.
Unser Ziel im Sinne von äh ja jetzt des Westens oder oder von von Europa und was ist denn jetzt eigentlich unser End- äh Game, aber erstmal äh ist dann natürlich die.
Die Frage ähm so hm na ja sind wir uns sind wir uns einig oder oder was was ist es?
Und wenn zum Beispiel jetzt unser Ziel, ich sage mal jetzt hypothetisch äh wäre äh ein schnelles Ende des Kriegs.
Ja dann äh könnten wir das wahrscheinlich sehr sehr schnell äh äh bewerkstelligen, so wenn wir das
äh wollten, aber wenn unser Ziel jetzt eine Schwächung von Putin und und Russland ist, dann wär's eigentlich
gut für unser Ziel den Krieg so lange wie möglich am Laufen zu halten. Ja äh und.
Ähm so äh in insofern wär's vielleicht mal ja äh zu gucken, so.
Was was ist es denn und und dann äh sind wir bei aller Liebe zur Ukraine. Es gibt natürlich auch Stimmen, die zu Recht darauf hinweisen, dass,
Aufgabe ja der Politiker auch im Westen ist, sich um unsere Interessen zu kümmern und nicht um die Interessen der Ukraine, auch wenn das jetzt erst mal kaltherzig klingt und dann gibt's ja auch noch von.
Von den Spruch okay Staaten hätten keine Freunde, äh sondern nur Interessen, aber ganz so einfach ist es natürlich auch nicht, weil,
bei den Interessen, wenn man jetzt selbst wenn man nur die Interessen äh betrachtet, dann gibt's natürlich kurzfristige Interessen und dann gibt's langfristige Interessen und die können natürlich auch komplett
äh entgegengesetzt sein. Also kurzfristige Interessen sind halt zum Beispiel eben auch möglichst billig zu tanken. Ja und äh möglichst
äh äh billig zu heizen, aber langfristiges äh Interesse ist halt jetzt nicht äh von weiß ich nicht von von äh Russland dann am Ende überrannt zu werden oder oder äh
dass ich äh und dann äh so mit mit Freundschaft unter.
Unter Staaten, ja mag sein, dass es da in dem Sinne keine Freundschaften gibt, aber man kann definitiv schon so was sagen, dass es jetzt unter Völkern äh durchaus Freundschaften äh äh gibt,
und
sich halt bestimmte Völker dann einfach näher äh stehen. Entweder weil sie auch vielleicht kulturell so bestimmte Gemeinsamkeiten haben oder.
Gemeinsame Interessen haben und sagen das und diese Freundschaft oder möglicherweise auch Feindschaft, weil irgendwie keine Ahnung man mal überfallen worden ist von denen, so dann äh äh wirkt das natürlich
auch äh diese Freundschaft und Feindschaft der einzelnen Leute äh bestimmt dann natürlich auch das staatliche Handeln und
Also in in insofern kann man jetzt
auch nicht einfach sagen, okay äh das sind unsere Interessen und das ist jetzt und deswegen äh verfolgen wir die jetzt und dann ähm das ist halt eben ein ein komplettes äh Zusammen
Spiel so und die andere Sache ist aber, äh jetzt, dass zum Beispiel äh man auch.
Jetzt zwischen kurz und langfristigen Interessen jetzt sagen, na ja, lass uns jetzt mal nur langfristig denken. Das geht halt auch nicht, weil du musst natürlich auch erst mal durchhalten bis sich
die äh äh ja das die die die langfristigen Interessen, die du verfolgt hast, sich dann auch irgendwann realisieren. Es nützt dir nichts, nur auf Langfrist zu sitzen, wenn du kurzfristig dabei verhungerst.
So insofern äh ja es ist es ist ein ein riesen kompliziertes äh
politisches Spiel, selbst wenn man jetzt nur in Interessen äh äh sich sich irgendwie anschaut und das auch wirkt dann natürlich auch jetzt die Frage der Sanktionierung von russischen Gas- und und,
äh so spielt es natürlich rein, klar.
Ähm langfristig wollen wir weg davon, aber äh kurzfristig äh so äh können wir's nicht. So äh wollen wir's wollen wir natürlich das möglichst aufrecht erhalten und so
Natürlich leider mit mit ganz ganz vielen anderen Dingen und was,
eben ja wir wir gerade so ein bisschen spielen als Westen, wenn wir jetzt spekulieren mag so, was sind denn jetzt.
Eigentlich unsere Interessen äh so die jetzt da grade verfolgt werden, ähm dann,
ist es ja äh was was so schön im im Jargon äh Banks versus Tanks genannt wird.
Und äh da gibt's dann eben auch auch wiederum verschiedene Ansichten so nach dem Motto, okay, was ist jetzt wichtiger? Die Banken oder die Panzer äh zu haben, aber auch da ist es so, dass man im Grunde genommen
beides braucht. Da gibt's dann eben auch den Spruch so it's the Banks not the tanks, aber das Gegenteil stimmt natürlich natürlich auch.
In dem äh äh Zusammenhang und äh du brauchst dann sowohl durch die die Wirtschaftskraft sage ich mal und du brauchst aber auch das das Militär und perverser Weise.
Je mehr du rüstest, umso schwächer wird natürlich deine Wirtschaft,
und umgekehrt, wenn du es schaffst, deinen Rüstungshaushalt möglichst niedrig zu halten, dann floriert natürlich die, die die Wirtschaft und,
insofern ja kommt man dann jetzt gerade auch in diese Diskussion Softpower und und und Hardpower und äh ähm,
die übrigens die wo die synergetische Kombination von Softpower und Hardpower dann auch gerne als Smart Power bezeichnet wird und das ist das Spiel, was die Amerikaner eigentlich versuchen zu spielen, dass du Militär.
Nutzt, um dort äh ja wirtschaftlich äh vorwärts zu kommen und da in der Wirtschaft so nutzt, dass äh du eben dann auch ein starkes äh Militär haben
kannst. Ja, jetzt habe ich äh viel äh viel abgespult äh jetzt gerade.
Aber ähm.
Bis unkonkret finde ich jetzt äh ne, ich meine, wenn du mich jetzt gefragt hättest, was ist das Endgame?
Würde erstmal so ein mittelfristiges Ziel äh definieren, was ich denke, was sich abzeichnet oder was vielleicht sinnvoll ist, denn eins hat der Krieg soweit schon gezeigt.
Mit dem System Putin wird man sich nicht mehr anfreunden können.
Das ist ja ne ist klar, Putin ist verbrannt.
Putin ist äh komplett verbrannt. Es wird keinerlei Einigung mit Putin äh geben können von der irgendjemand meint äh da können wir uns damit können wir uns irgendwie arrangieren. Das wird ja schon einhalten. Ähm so.
Das bedeutet aber auch, meiner Auffassung nach, dass.
All die ganzen Landgewinner, die er da jetzt in in der Ukraine in den letzten sechs Jahren oder acht Jahren äh vollzogen hat, also sowohl dem Donalds Luhansk als eben auch auf der Krim im Prinzip rückgängig gemacht werden muss.
Das ist halt einfach nicht tragbar. Das war vorher schon nicht tragbar und äh niemand kann dafür garantieren, dass sozusagen nicht alles wieder von vorne losgeht und Europa kann sich einfach keinen Konfliktherd leisten, auch nicht so einen, der jetzt irgendwie vor sich hinmurmelt, wie
da im ganzen Donbass. Das heißt.
Nicht nur ist eine ein Abzug der Russen aus der Ukraine äh geboten. Es ist im Prinzip auch der Abzug aus der Krim.
Und aus dem Donbass geboten. Alles andere wäre eigentlich für Europa und den Westen schon eine Niederlage. Jetzt wird einfach so lange, müssen die Daumenschrauben so lange angezogen werden, bis das erfolgt.
Die die Russen das überhaupt nicht gerne tun werden. Das ist vollkommen klar. Das wird auch kein einfacher Weg, aber wir haben ja gerade darüber gesprochen.
Ist das Ziel? Was was ist jetzt sozusagen das Minimum, was man eigentlich erzielen will und
Das ist natürlich aus Sicht Europas ist es quasi die die Abwesenheit von Bedrohung und die lodert natürlich in diesen Gebieten äh extrem, sprich die Herstellung
vollständigen Staatsgebiets der Ukraine muss eine Staatsräson sein. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das sich langfristig auch so.
Tragen wird, aber derzeit würde ich sagen, ist so der Sagen, so der politische Wind weht in diese Richtung, ne. Wie wie lange äh weiß ich nicht. Denn wenn man sich's jetzt mal andersrum dreht.
Würde denn jetzt passieren, wenn man eben weiterhin so auf du na ja Ukraine, was betrifft uns das? Wir sind ja wir müssen ja nur auf unsere eigene Sicherheit bedacht sein.
Würde das jetzt einfach alles so laufen lassen und man hätte jetzt überhaupt so Ukraine was was interessiert Insta und Stars und wie ihr mit euren Schauspielern und Profiboxern irgendwie äh euch nehmt doch eh keiner ernst äh und geil so äh wir hören jetzt
auf Linke und AfD äh rollt da mal rein irgendwie. Äh wir waren ja auch ganz böse zu euch. Was würde dann passieren? Er würde halt wirklich die Ukraine komplett nehmen.
Weitgehend zerstören,
äh die Gebiete mindestens bis Transnistrien, wenn nicht sogar auch noch Moldawien äh in dem Abwasch auch noch mitnehmen und hätte im Prinzip so die alten
Grenzen der UDSSR abzüglich äh
Ungarn, Slowakei, Polen, Tschechien, Rumänien äh wieder hergestellt so und das wäre dann das Stale mit der Zukunft.
Beziehungsweise das Problem ist wovon man ausgeht ist wenn das jetzt irgendwie
Ja äh gut ausgeht für Putin wie auch immer äh das dann ja nicht Schluss ist. So,
sondern äh die Pläne, die er ja auch schon mehrfach dargelegt hat, ist, äh dass er auch äh sozusagen Polen aus der NATO äh wieder raushaben will.
So
Ja? Öh plus wahrscheinlich Rumänien, Bulgarien sollen sagen, die werden dann sozusagen die nächste Ukraine, wo dann ja ganz klar Forderungen formuliert hat, dass er sozusagen.
NATO auf den Stand von 2007 zurückrollen will, ja? Drunter macht das nicht,
ja? Plus ähm dann noch äh die anderen also im Grunde genommen alle, ich sage mal abtrünnigen Sowjet-Republiken äh sollen wieder Heim ins Reich geholt werden und äh alle
wie gesagt die nach 2007 wohl oder.
Äh nee, was weiß ich, ja. Ähm jedenfalls äh möchte er eben auch die NATO äh zurückrollen. Tschechien möchte er nicht wiederhaben übrigens. Also Tschechien möchte er nicht raushaben aus der aus der NATO. Also Tschechien ist sicher äh,
noch.
Na Gott sei Dank.
Ja, ja, also zumindest hat er das das das nicht gefordert. So. Deswegen,
ist jetzt nicht nur äh sozusagen jetzt reine Rachsucht oder äh sagen nee, der darf jetzt nicht irgendwie äh äh diesen Erfolg haben aus psychologischen
gründen oder weil weil wir das ungerecht finden äh irgendwie, sondern weil halt klar ist äh so
dass äh ja ähm er nicht nicht Schluss machen wird äh mit der Ukraine, wenn er dort
Erfolg hat. Das heißt, ähm er muss gestoppt werden, ja und äh eben
in den Grenzen von von Russland so, dass es äh das ist denke ich ganz ganz klar jetzt äh mindestens das Ziel des Westens. So und dann ist jetzt die Frage okay wie kann man ihnen
jetzt äh stoppen.
Und äh ja äh und natürlich einen einen eine militärische Katastrophe in der in der Ukraine oder in ein eine militärische Niederlage jetzt äh in der Ukraine wäre.
Natürlich einen einen wirklich äh guter Schritt äh hin äh auf auf dieses dieses Ziel,
tatsächlich äh sollten wir, damit wir, meine ich jetzt auch, speziell Politik und Politiker und äh sollten wir alles,
unterlassen, äh was uns äh den den den Westen jetzt irgendwie schlecht.
Aussehen lässt, weil im Moment ist ist klar, die Welt,
ist äh komplett gegen gegen Putin, das kann man halt an dieser UN-Abstimmung äh an dieser Resolution feststellen, wo dann äh außer äh Russland eben,
nur äh ja Weißrussland äh Äthiopien.
Und Eritrea äh glaube ich dagegen waren und nicht mal nicht mal die Chinesen haben dagegen gestimmt, sondern sich sich enthalten und dann weiß ich nicht
das also so viele Länder haben glaube ich lange nicht mehr so einer Resolution
äh dann äh dann zugestimmt wie im Moment gegen äh die gegen Russland so und,
was man eben auf gar keinen Fall jetzt will bis irgendwie Putin nachträglich irgendwelche
begründet zu liefern, so nach dem Motto seht ihr
der Westen wollte uns jetzt doch irgendwie klein und fertig machen und deswegen war das total gerechtfertigt, dass wir da jetzt reingegangen sind, weil der Westen wollte ja auch nicht an der Ukraine jetzt Schluss
äh äh machen, sondern eigentlich wollten die uns jetzt äh äh ja wollten die noch noch viel schlimmeres und deswegen war das jetzt gerechtfertigt.
Und äh ja in insofern äh sagen jetzt auf
auf der Ebene äh äh denke ich, es ist politische Zurückhaltung geboten und.
Ja was was jetzt auch das das Militärische angeht bis jetzt
dann natürlich die große Frage, äh große Debatte, ja jetzt Nofly Zone und warum gehen wir da jetzt nicht mit Militär rein, hatten wir ja auch gesagt, wenn da jetzt der Westen oder die Natron militärisch reingehen würde.
So konventionell hätte da Russland nichts wirklich entgegen
äh zu setzen, ja. Also sehen wir jetzt schon, dass selbst äh sie Probleme haben im Moment
äh mit einer ukrainischen Armee äh dort dort das unter Kontrolle zu kriegen und äh,
ja und der Westen hatten wir ja auch schon über die NATO, wie gesagt, ist so grob zehn zu1äh überlegen äh den den den Großen, so.
Insofern können wir militärisch zumindest auch so
bisschen äh aus einer Position der Stärke äh durchaus agieren und durchaus sagen etwas entspannter.
Sein äh was was das,
angeht, weil äh wie gesagt Russland äh einfach nicht wie das zu zu Zeiten der Sowjetunion war, wo die Sowjetunion massiv
überlegen äh war konventionell und äh die NATO
bei einer äh Sowjetischen Invasion oder einer Invasion des Warschauer Pakts äh einfach wir konventionell dem wenig entgegenzusetzen gehabt hätten und
eigentlich nur dann den Vormarsch äh mit Atomwaffen hätten stoppen können. Das war auch.
Fest eingeplant. Was noch damals gab's irgendwie noch weiß nicht die Use uralten Nike Nike Herkules, Luftabwehrraketen.
Wo die so eine Rakete gleichzeitig steuern äh konnten und wenn äh dort jetzt, ich sage mal, mehr als.
Ein Flugzeug gekommen wäre. So äh ein ganzes Geschwader äh dann dann werden die halt in Frankreich gewesen äh und wir hätten irgendwie drei davon abschießen können. Weshalb halt dort auch die Nike Hercules äh für die es Atomsprengköpfe gab und da war tatsächlich der Plan
äh so jetzt die größere russische Luftangriffe tatsächlich atomar äh zu beantworten.
Das hat sich jetzt aber quasi genau umgekehrt. Äh das äh konventionelle Kräfteverhältnis,
und ähm das heißt äh umgekehrt könnte halt äh Russland jetzt äh NATO-Truppen konventionell nicht stoppen und müsste seinerseits dann
äh bei einem bei einem Angriff auf auf Russland, dann atomar äh reagieren andere Chance hätte es nicht.
Und womit wir dann äh bei der, glaube ich, auch jetzt bei der dritten dritte Weltkrieg und Atomdebatte äh angekommen wären.
Na ja gut schießt mir jetzt ein bisschen weit äh voraus. Ich meine jetzt haben wir erstmal die Situation die kurzfristige Situation, ne? Also.
Mhm. Okay.
Wir haben uns jetzt gefragt, was was sollte das Endgame sein und das ist natürlich auch etwas, was was die kurzfristigen Handlungen leiten sollte. Man muss natürlich ein Ziel haben, man muss irgendeinem Stern äh auch folgen können und ich würde halt sagen,
Es wäre für Europa eine Blamage.
Erster Güteklasse. Allein schon, wenn es jetzt den Russen gelingen würde, sagen wir mal, den Selenski zu killen.
Stell dir vor, was dann los wäre. Ja, also so das Symbol des ukrainischen Widerstands grade.
Aber da hat Putin schon schon.
Offiziell zumindest wohl wohl umgeschwenkt. Äh habe ich gehört äh so ähm also eine der Bedingungen bei diesen Verhandlungen, die ja auch immer wieder stattfinden, war ja äh Selensky muss weg.
Tatrussland äh jetzt wohl in den letzten Verhandlungen gesagt, okay, Selenski darf bleiben.
Ja, aber ich glaube, die war halt ein Scheiß.
So, ne und ich ich sage jetzt einfach mal hypothetisch, angenommen, das wäre jetzt so. Keine Ahnung, kann ja auch was schiefgehen, fliegt eine Rakete äh in in Kiew da äh steht ja immer ganz stolz da an seinem Fenster. Die wissen, wo das Fenster ist.
Wissen auch, wie man eine Rakete reinfliegt. So, die haben die haben irgendwie die Technologie, die die können da reinballern.
So, jetzt hätten Sie schon längst tun können und äh mir kann keiner eine Garantie dafür geben, dass
dass das dann äh passiert. So und jetzt sagen wir einfach mal, es passiert, ne oder seiner Familie äh stößt was zu oder in irgendeiner Form wird überhaupt das ganze Government da ausgehebelt oder die oder auch nur Kiev äh jetzt.
Noch stärker zerstört auch. Ja, ist ja auch kulturelle Elemente, Museen et cetera, was da sich schon alles draufgegangen ist. Das ist das ist ja jetzt alles schon ein totales Desaster. Das wäre für Europa eine Riesenblamage.
Und generell wäre überhaupt ein also ein in in irgendeiner Form messbares Überrollen dieses Landes.
Und einen Vergrößerung des Leidens.
Wir's jetzt haben. Über ein bestimmtes Maß hinaus, was ich jetzt nicht quantifizieren kann. So ein gefühltes Überschreiten einer bestimmten Belastung.
Es gibt mhm.
Muss verhindert werden. So und ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen derzeit das, was ist, ne? Und wie du schon sagtest, wahrscheinlich sind diese Waffenlieferungen in die Ukraine.
Jenseits aller öffentlichen Ankündigungen massiv. Ich gehe davon aus, dass da,
ohne Ende grade Gerät reingefahren wird, so nach dem Motto hier, habt da Macht irgendwie tut äh damit ihr einfach was. Ich meine, da stehen die Leute in Schlangen an und wollen sich irgendwie bewaffnen lassen, weil sie so einen hohen Freiwilligenzulauf haben, den,
nur die Anzahl äh Gewehre. Ähm um dieses Ziel.
Äh zu sichern, müssen sie im Prinzip diesen Widerstand maximal machen und wenn es halt jetzt dann wirklich so kommt.
Die Sanktionen so greifen, dass dass die Wirtschaft zusammenbricht, dass Russland einfach irgendwann auch in seiner Logistik.
Erschlafft oder es halt auch einfach organisatorisch nicht auf die Kette äh kriegt, ihr ganzes Gerät.
Zusammenfällt und sie dann irgendwann auch noch so diese Blamage haben, dass sogar ihr Rückzug irgendwie noch zum großen Desaster wird, ne, weil das ist natürlich auch das Problem, wenn die dann erst mal merken, okay, geht's wirklich keinen Schritt mehr voran. Jetzt müssen wir zurück.
Sonst chillen die uns irgendwie alle, dann wird's natürlich noch mal richtig blutig. Und dann sind so eine Gegenbewegungen gibt, dann wird sich das natürlich dann auch,
Stellen sie sich halt auch die Frage so, okay alles klar, jetzt stehen wir hier irgendwie an einer Krim, was machen wir jetzt, ne? Und das ist.
Die eine Frage, dann das andere.
Ist ja halt dieses Geeiere um wie inwiefern soll man zugreifen. Jetzt haben wir diesen Fall mit den Flugzeugen.
Kampfflugzeugen, den russischen also den polnischen Kampfflugzeugen russischer Bauart, habe grad das Kürzel vergessen, aber die Polen haben so was natürlich noch.
Nicht nur die Polen, auch andere Länder, ja. Aha und äh genau, die Polen haben die, glaube ich, auch wiederum von der NVA äh äh eine ganze Menge übernommen. Ist bestimmt gut gewartet. Ähm.
Ja, gut, da gibt's also irgend so ein so ein Sowjet ähm RA Restbestand so, ne und das ist halt auch etwas, worin.
Die Ukraine halt ausgebildete Piloten hat. Das heißt, es sind Flugzeuge, die könnten halt theoretisch von der Armee auch zum Einsatz kommen. Jetzt könnte man sagen.
Waffe. Von der Luft.
Für mich ist Armee alles, aber okay klar, Bodentruppen, was anderes. Ähm da gibt's jetzt viel Geeiere dadrum, ne? Die Polen wollen die nicht direkt liefern, sondern wollen das ja mit den Amerikanern liefern, damit die Amerikaner das liefern. Die Amerikaner so nö, heiße Kartoffel fassen wir nicht an.
Überhaupt nichts voran, weil halt der Tanz ist immer derselbe, nämlich der.
Was können wir tun, was nicht irgendwie diesen Eindruck erweckt? Wir würden uns ja am Krieg beteiligen, obwohl wir uns ja de facto bereits am Krieg beteiligen. Ja, wir sind im Krieg.
Russland.
Deswegen stehen wir auch auf der Liste feindlicher Länder, Herr.
Ja und äh Russland sagt ja auch schon so, ja allein schon die Sanktionen sind ja im Prinzip schon Kriegserklärung.
Genau wir befinden uns erstens in einem Wirtschaftskrieg.
Von Ausmaßen wie in die Welt glaube ich so noch nicht gesehen hat äh so gerade plus eben ja die militärische Unterstützung, also.
Das ist äh mit mit also.
Ja, aber vielleicht noch mal, dass da sozusagen ein eins Szenario äh nochmal ähm was so allgemein befürchtet wird, äh wie das Ganze jetzt nochmal äh zu einem direkten Konflikt eskalieren.
Äh kann und zwar richtig sagte, wenn das Ganze jetzt, ich meine, es ist so schon eine riesige humanitäre Katastrophe, aber,
Wenn diese Katastrophe jetzt, ich sage mal, annähernd irgendwann, ich sage mal Völkermordsdimensionen bekommt so. Haben wir ja auch in Jugoslawien äh gesehen, so plötzlich keine Ahnung.
Äh ja äh jede Menge tote Massengräber, äh eine verhungernde, also Millionen drohen zu verhungern.
Ähm ja äh dann ähm wird und davon gehen halt Experten aus.
Wird halt auch die NATO, deren rote Linie ja ganz klar ist, wir wollen keine direkte militärische Konfrontation oder kein kein Einsatz von Militär
in der Ukraine, aber äh,
diese roten Linien hat die NATO ja früher auch häufiger äh dann.
Überschritten oder überschreiten müssen, weil einfach auch der Aufschrei in der Bevölkerung weil man einfach nicht tatenlos zusehen konnte. Ja und in die Situation konnte man dann auch kommen, so Stück für Stück, das könnte vielleicht damit anfangen,
dass man halt äh Militär zum Schutz jetzt von äh humanitären Versorgungskonvois äh mitschickt äh so
das könnte dann ja möglicherweise unter Beschuss geraten und äh schon hätten wir dann jetzt eine direkte Konfrontation äh zwischen
NATO-Militär und russischen äh Militär in der Ukraine
dann natürlich weiter eskalieren äh könnte, weil wenn man dann äh wirklich falls falls dann jetzt zum Beispiel.
Die Russen irgendwann.
Doch vielleicht Lufthoheit gewinnen sollten, was jetzt nicht der Fall ist, weswegen ich auch glaube, dass das grade hm.
Diese Flugzeuggeschichte, dass sich jetzt die am das jetzt alle zieren, die die die Flugzeuge zu liefern,
glaube ich auch daran, dass das Gefühl besteht, die werden auch jetzt gerade im Moment noch nicht gebraucht. Ja so das das, ich glaube, man hebt sich das.
Ja ja, man hebt sich das jetzt jetzt gerade auf, weil ähm so die äh russische Luftwaffe ist nicht besonders aktiv.
Über der Ukraine, weil sie halt auch Angst haben, weil sie halt auch äh glaube ich eine ganze Menge Probleme haben und schon verdammt viel teures Gerät verloren.
Haben, weil die ukrainische Luftabwehr äh immer noch aktiv ist, weil die Luftwaffe immer noch aktiv ist und weil natürlich jetzt tausende von Stingern äh dort unterwegs sind, mit denen man
auch Kampfflugzeuge abschießen, ganz zwar nur mit 10 Prozent Trefferwahrscheinlichkeit gegenüber den 80 Prozent bei Hubschraubern, aber nichtsdestotrotz so.
Deswegen glaube ich, äh dass dass man äh da auch dann dann jetzt erstmal das das deswegen zurückgestellt hat. Aber
meines Wissens äh haben die Polen schon Flugzeuge in Ramstein jetzt abgekippt.
So wo die jetzt gerade den NATO fixiert
äh äh werden und umgestrichen werden. Ich glaube, die werden da jetzt äh einfach jetzt erst mal eine Weile parken
und äh dann wird man gucken, falls die Verluste der ukrainischen Luftwaffe dann zu hoch werden oder die Situation weiter eskaliert, kann ich mir das vorstellen, dass man
die auch noch liefern wird plus man hat natürlich dann jetzt auch so ein bisschen ein Faustpfand in der Hand so nach dem Motto okay liebe Russen, wenn ihr eskaliert, dann äh schicken wir halt doch die
die die Flugzeuge rüber. So das das ist meine Vermutung was da jetzt grade äh das das das politische Kalkül.
Ist natürlich auch ein bisschen zynisch äh so äh die Ukrainer da hängen zu lassen, aber ich ich glaube ähm.
Dass das da tatsächlich eine Rolle spielt, dass man das Gefühl hat, okay ähm wir brauchen's im Moment wahrscheinlich noch noch gar nicht.
Du dir da eigentlich sicher, dass die Polen das schon übergeben haben, weil ich sehe hier immer so Nachrichten wie Titel schreibt, also im Titel steht dann Polen übergibt die Jets wie er in Deutschland an die USA und dann im Artikel steht drin äh Polen ist bereit das zu tun.
Es ist auch äh manchmal wirklich schwierig im Journalismus sich zurechtzufinden.
Mhm. Ähm.
Ja gut ich meine du hast so einen Tweet abgesetzt.
Auch schon gesagt hast, äh mal gut, dass du kein Bundeskanzler bist. Weil du wärst schon längst durchgedreht.
Ja also ich äh was heißt durch.
Das ja mal kurz aus so einer emotionalen Perspektive heraus äh betrachten.
Ja, ja, ja. Also,
Genau, da sind und da sind wir jetzt äh dann mittendrin, ich sage mal, im, im, im, im nuklearen Poker oder äh wer auch immer in äh so und.
Da ist natürlich dann erstens die Frage, so ist Putin eigentlich,
verrückt geworden, es war wahnsinnig, ist ja unzurechnungsfähig, so was ja auch immer jetzt vielfach äh äh postuliert wurde, keine Ahnung, äh Beginn der Altersdemenz und,
äh Corona-Koller und äh keine Ahnung, was was da alles äh jetzt schon gesagt wurde und.
Ähm.
Mein Eindruck ist und ich habe mir so ein paar Fernsehauftritte, so ein paar jüngste Fernsehauftritte von Putin auch einfach angeschaut und aus meiner Sicht.
War der Mann, machte auf mich einen äh ziemlich.
Gesunden Eindruck äh sage ich mal, äh fit und äh ja und ich und ich glaube auch nicht, äh dass dass er verrückt äh war oder dass dass dieser Einsatz oder dass dieser,
Überfall der Ukraine jetzt eine eine schwachsinnige Idee äh war innerhalb
seiner seiner Logik, sondern er war einfach nur schlecht informiert beziehungsweise ist halt von falschen Voraussetzungen ausgegangen, aber
äh er hatte aber auch gute Gründe von diesen falschen Voraussetzungen aus. Sie haben ja schon erwähnt, bei der Krim irgendwie, die sind alle weggerannt, haben ihre Waffen hingeworfen. Es gab zwei Tote und äh die Leute haben hurra geschrieben, so das heißt, es gab durchaus auch Annahmen des zumal.
Jetzt Selensky auch so beliebt nicht nicht wahr im im letzten halben Jahr, riesige Probleme hatte und so ist es durchaus sein konnte, dass,
ähm wenn äh jetzt auch äh sich aus dem Weg aufm aus dem Land gemacht hätte und er seine Marionette da hätte äh
einsetzen können, ja hätte das Ganze durchaus äh relativ
schnell mit überschaubaren, negativen Konsequenzen. Klar, der Westen hätte dann auch nochmal Sanktionen auf äh gestockt, aber nicht in dem Maße, wie das jetzt passiert ist.
So. Da habe ich dann auch gehört, das waren so die tatsächlich die entscheidenden 8undvierzig Stunden am Anfang ähm so wo
klar wurde, äh dass es nicht so läuft, äh wie er sich das das vorgestellt hat.
Und das hat dem Westen eben Mut und Zeit gegeben sich zu konsolidieren und äh sagen auch diese diese Antwort dann zu bringen. Wäre jetzt, ich sage mal, am dritten Tag äh wäre.
Wäre da ein neuer ukrainischer Präsident
im im Amt gewesen und hätte jetzt den Oberbefehl über Polizei und Militär übernommen und die russischen Truppen, ja klar hätte man natürlich auch diese Sanktionen ausgeweitet, aber alles nicht nicht in dem Maße
So, das heißt, er hätte dann auch wieder einen einfach einen Erfolg für sich verbuchen können, alles super. So ist jetzt nicht so gelaufen.
Und äh deswegen, wie gesagt, glaube ich nicht, dass da jetzt irgendwie verrückt ist oder irgendwie ja geistig,
psychische Einschränkungen. Gut, er ist paranoid,
so das sieht man an den langen Tischen aber das heißt nicht dass jetzt niemand nicht versucht ihn wirklich umzubringen so also ich glaube er hat auch durchaus gute Gründe so für seine für seine Paranoia Plus natürlich,
dass man immer den anderen genau das zutraut, was man eben auch selber tut und wenn man halt ja schon Poloniummörder und und Nervengasmörder äh in der Welt rumschickt äh.
Man natürlich ganz klar die Vorstellung, die anderen machen das auch so oder meine eigenen Leute machen das auch so. Insofern muss man davon aus, dass Putin schon.
Rational denkt und handelt, nur eben schlecht informiert äh ist und,
was jetzt die Vermutung ist, was äh was er jetzt eben auch als als nächstes tun wird, weil womit er ja auch schon begonnen hat, ist weiter
zu eskalieren. Also einmal das Thema Cyber
äh so, was vielleicht auch im anderen Kontext schon vorher ist, aber es gab ja jetzt diesen merkwürdigen Ausfall der der
Anlagen äh in der Berliner Verwaltung vor drei Tagen
wo auch niemand weiß, was das jetzt genau gewesen ist, aber wie die Notrufnummern gegen einen halben Tag nicht und die Verwaltung hat nicht miteinander telefonieren und so, hm, keine Ahnung.
Ein Ausfall gewesen sein, aber nichts, nichts weiß man nicht. Also Cyber ist sozusagen das das eine Thema, äh das ich jetzt aber nicht nicht aufmachen wollte, sondern ähm.
Entlang. Es gibt so die die die Vermutung und die fand ich durchaus glaubwürdig, dass.
Putins Strategie jetzt ist hm,
oder sein wird, so nah wie möglich an einen dritten Weltkrieg heranzueskalieren. Das heißt, gewissermaßen so ein Game of Chicken zu spielen, aber
ohne wirklich jetzt den dritten Weltkrieg auszulösen, sodass das will er jetzt nicht
So ich glaube nicht, dass er jetzt so äh ja nach dem Motto okay, also bevor mein Russland äh irgendwie zerfällt so, dann soll die Welt lieber in Schutt und Asche äh liegen, ähm so
Ich denke nicht, dass das das äh das ist wie wie wie er tickt. Aber.
Also ich glaube, wie er tickt ist, dass er halt.
Ja die westlichen Politiker alle für Luschen und Weicheier hält und für für Feiglinge und dass er eigentlich nur.
Spiel so so weit eskalieren muss, dass den allen der Schreck in die Knochen fährt und die ganze Situation dann jetzt,
durchrütteln und und auseinanderrütteln und dann gucken wohin die Steine so fallen und dann zusehen, dass da dann möglichst viele äh Vorteile dann aus der aus dieser Situation
rausholt so äh mit anderen Worten,
Es könnte gut sein, äh dass eben Putin von sich aus äh dann äh jetzt Eskalation beginnen äh will oder vorantreiben äh will.
Äh wenn das nicht gelingt, dann wurde auch sogar schon spekuliert, dass es sein könnte, äh dass er schon irgendwo äh eine taktische Atomwaffe zündet oder
einsetzt, um mhm ja äh einfach äh die Welt aufzurütteln.
Äh muss nicht notwendigerweise tatsächlich gegen einen gegen ein wirkliches Ziel äh sein
äh so aber wahrscheinlich würde er sie irgendwo gegen die Amerikaner einsetzen äh wenn dann nicht gegen Europa war so die die Vermutung und,
möglicherweise auch so, dass es jetzt äh vielleicht keine oder keine große Zahl von von Opfern gibt, aber dass eben möglichst,
keine Ahnung in der Nähe von einem amerikanischen Flottenverband oder Militärstütz,
plötzlich äh entweder so ein nuklearer Torpedo oder irgendwas anderes explodiert und äh.
Dass das äh sozusagen äh irgendwann in den nächsten Monaten äh äh dann passieren könnte
wo er dann die Welt aufrüttelt und alle in Angst und Schrecken hängen und dann sich alle sagen, oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott äh nein
jetzt jetzt müssen wir halt irgendwie uns mit ihm arrangieren was es wolle, so dass es glaube ich äh so oder das könnten.
Könnte das würde zu ihm passen, so. Ja, weil was bleibt ihm denn.
Äh äh sonst noch so. Was kann er denn? Was was kann er denn sonst äh noch so machen? Ja, ich meine, was sollen wir tun.
Was soll man nicht tun? Wir sind ja schon moderat am,
eskalieren jetzt in der letzten äh Zeit, aber ich denke äh so wir sollten halt äh schon.
Eben.
Vorsichtig sein äh mit äh äh tatsächlich mit mit weiteren äh Eskalationsschritten, sofern äh sie nicht.
Nötig sind oder äh so sofern wir das nicht tun müssen, weil idealerweise äh so äh,
ja äh warten wir jetzt ab beziehungsweise ähm führen halt diese Unterstützung, die wir sowieso schon leisten,
entsprechend äh weiter, also Waffenlieferungen äh äh Finanzen ähm
Essen äh was auch immer äh sagen die die Ukraine auf jeden Fall äh weiter zu versorgen, auch mit mit Informationen. Aber äh das Level sozusagen nicht,
steigern,
äh wenn es nicht unbedingt sein muss. Das heißt durchaus auch gewisse äh vielleicht russische ähm,
Provokationen äh einfach mal ignorieren, was was eben auch.
So äh teilweise ja der Fall ist, also als die Russen irgendwie äh ihre atomare Alarmbereitschaft.
Gesteigert haben sind die Amerikaner ja nicht mitgezogen und deswegen.
Äh denke ich äh einfach cool bleiben und Ruhe bewahren. So das äh.
Aber wie soll man denn jetzt cool bleiben und die Ruhe bewahren, wenn halt jetzt die humanitäre Situation in der Ukraine eskaliert? So und meine es ist doch absolut nachvollziehbar, dass äh ein Teil.
Der Öffentlichkeit auch in Deutschland sicherlich auch anderswo in Europa. Mittlerweile halt immer wieder diese Frage nach No Fly Zone äh stellt. Was
das jetzt so dass sozusagen das Aufrechterhalten einer solchen no fliese und wirklich sofort bedeuten würde, unmittelbare aktive Kriegsbeteiligung.
Ist klar, ja? Aber was die Leute damit ja meinen, ist ja etwas anderes, was sie damit meinen, ist, Europa sollte.
Alles tun, Europa im Sinne von NATO, im Sinne von der Westen, ne? Sollte alles tun, um diese.
Humanitäre Katastrophe und wie du ja auch schon gesagt hast, dieser potenzielle,
im Raum stehende Genozid, weil das haben wir ja nun durchaus auch schon äh gesehen. Wir haben auch gesehen, wie sich Russland in Syrien äh verhalten hat und
Nicht wahr? Es gibt einfach genug schlechte Beispiele und ähm da will man dann nicht auch erst reagieren, wenn's schon wieder alles zu spät ist.
Also ist halt die Frage, was können wir jetzt real tun und wie weit muss man sich nach vorne treiben und ist es überhaupt.
Geboten irgendwie immer wie soll ich sagen.
Sagen seine Schwäche da zu zelebrieren. Äh ich bin noch nicht der Meinung, dass man jetzt einen dicken Max machen soll. Ich bin da eigentlich genauso verzweifelt wie alle anderen auch, dass ich irgendwo das Gefühl habe,
Man müsse irgendwie einschreiten, ne, aber mir nicht sicher bin, ob wirklich schon alles getan wird, was getan werden sollte.
Also man kann erstmal feststellen, ich meine trotz trotz allem läuft es halt für die Russen schlecht.
Und äh für uns immer im Moment nicht so schlecht. Ja oder für den für den Westen oder auch für die für die Ukraine so. Ähm das heißt äh so ähm.
Unterschiedliche Definitionen von schlecht. Also ich meine natürlich läuft es gerade für die Ukraine extrem schlecht.
Ja ja aber nicht aber wesentlich besser als jeder vor zwei Wochen erwartet hätte. Ja also äh das das kann man glaube ich auch oder als die meisten.
Aber das wird jetzt auch niemanden richtig glücklich machen.
So, nee, nee. Ähm.
Aber äh so was was sind denn die Optionen? So grundsätzlich kann man halt ja eskalieren, deeskalieren oder äh das,
aktuelle Level äh an Unterstützung und Engagement beibehalten und ich denke äh das mittlere
Ähm also beibehalten äh so äh ist erstmal ähm das, was das Klügste ist.
Und äh dann äh zu gucken äh wie sich das alles jetzt weiter entwickelt.
Das Problem ist natürlich, wie du auch richtig gesagt hattest, wenn sich jetzt diese humanitäre Katastrophe weiter verschlimmert und so was wie ja
Völkermorddimensionen erreicht oder Millionen Menschen in der Ukraine plötzlich von Hunger äh bedroht äh sind äh oder es dazu ja
Säuberungen äh kommt und irgendwelchen Gulags oder Straflagern oder was weiß ich, was wir so in Jugoslawien alles gesehen haben.
Dann ja wird man eben auch weiter eskalieren müssen ähm so und äh weitere Schritte vornehmen.
Welche Schritte können das sein?
Ich meine, wenn man jetzt in dieser ganzen Dritte Weltkrieg verhindern Logik bleibt, ja, gibt's ja sozusagen gar keine weiteren Schritte mehr. Weil ja immer da so das Label draufsteht mit wenn du jetzt irgendwas machst, ja dann ist ja sofort Nuklearkrieg.
Nee nee so also ich würde sagen die die so die Nukleardrohungen erstmal weitgehend ignorieren.
Weil wenn Putin verrückt ist und vorhat den Knopf zu drücken so, dann ist es völlig egal, was wir jetzt gerade äh machen, ja wenn wenn das sein sein Ziel ist oder er nicht eher so irrational,
ist äh so, dann ja dann hilft nur ein atomaler Erstschlag äh so, ja? Aber das äh wäre ja wer
Wahnsinn. Ähm aber nee, ich meine weitere Eskalationsschritte wären dann, wenn's zu dieser humanitären Katastrophe kommt, äh dass man äh dann schon äh sehr wohl ja äh äh Truppen
in die Ukraine schickt,
um eben die humanitären Konvois zu schützen beispielsweise. Das wäre dann so äh der ein, ein nächster Eskalationsschritt oder eben
Flugzeuge äh äh zu liefern oder die Waffenlieferungen noch mal auszuweiten. So, also da gibt's gibt's schon äh äh noch noch weitere Eskalationsschritte, die die möglich wären.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist doch unrealistisch. Also wenn ihr jetzt sozusagen sagt, als erster Schritt schicken wir erst mal Bodentruppen.
Denn nicht als ersten Schritt. Das das wäre aber sozusagen ein Schritt der
erforderlich äh oder unvermeidbar äh sein könnte, wenn sagen die Situation sich noch äh entsprechend weiterentwickelt.
Ja gut, aber dann dann wäre doch dann ist doch eine No Fly so in gewisser Hinsicht schon realistischer. Also ich meine, das ist ja dann auch sehr viel äh einfacher in Anführungsstrichen äh herzustellen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, weil ähm wenn du jetzt, ich sage mal einfach Truppen zum Schutz von
humanitären Lieferungen dort hinein
schickst. Ja und dann äh ähm diese angegriffen werden, dann bist du nicht nicht derjenige, der den Angriff durchgeführt hat, sondern dann verteidigst du.
Ja? Das äh wäre halt ein wichtiges Ding. Ein No-Fly-Zone,
ganz praktisch äh wie das halt abläuft äh so eine No-Fly Zone, was das bedeutet ist, dass du erst mal äh etwas machst. Das nennt sich.
Seat, also SEAD, Supreshion of eir defense. Und,
das bedeutet, dass du dann wie wir das in anderen Kriegen gesehen haben, dass so mit äh Cruise Missale und äh Stars-Bombern und äh Kampfflugzeugen und
mit 'ner Kombination quasi erstmal die Luftabwehr der Russen ausschaltest. Und das Problem dabei ist, dass 'nen Großteil
der Luftabwehr, die du ausschalten musst, auch auf russischem und weißrussischen Territorium.
Steht. Das heißt, äh das würde halt bedeuten, äh dass äh ja wir sagen russischen Boden
angreifen und bombardieren müssten, weil anders geht's halt nicht. Ja, das bedeutet halt eine No-Fly.
Äh Sohn effektiv. Und äh ja und dann dann werden wir ganz ganz schnell ähm so im im im dritten Welt, dann wären wir mittendrin im in einem heißen dritten Weltkrieg, so.
Welches Land äh würdest du sagen würde Truppen für so eine humanitäre Mission.
Die Amerikaner werden wahrscheinlich dann diejenigen vielleicht auch einige Europäer wahrscheinlich NATO also einen irgendwie kombinierter NATO-Einsatzverband damit sich da kein Land äh zu sehr äh,
poniert, äh so dass das das wäre das Ding, aber je länger ich drüber nachdenke, mh ist es so,
die Russen müssten eigentlich bald
merken, dass sie, dass sie nicht nicht wirklich die Fähigkeit zur Eskalation äh haben
und äh insofern könnte ich mir auch vorstellen
dass es da auch bald äh einen einen Sinneswandel oder eine eine äh der der Russen ergibt. Ich meine, bisher wurde immer spekuliert, okay sie werden.
Eskalieren, ausweiten, hatten wir ja vorhin vorhin schon brutaler bombardieren und äh
Aber vielleicht passiert auch genau das Gegenteil. So dass sie halt merken, okay äh läuft so nicht und äh vielleicht wären wir halt.
Schneller.
An den an den Punkt äh kommen, wo es zu wo es zu ernsthaften Verhandlungen und zu einem Waffenstillstand kommt. Das sehe ich durchaus auch nochmal als als Variante, äh die sich, die sich auftut, also zumindest
glaube ich wird Russland auf jeden Fall versuchen, jetzt demnächst Zeit zu gewinnen.
So äh weil sie das wie gesagt mit der Intensität äh nicht gerade nicht nicht nicht durchhalten können. Das heißt
möglicherweise werden die Russen jetzt auch auf versuchen auf Zeit zu spielen und das Ganze nimmt erstmal an Intensität ab oder oder es kommt vielleicht erstmal zu einem Waffenstillstand, den die Russen dann nutzen, um ihre Positionen.
Konsolidieren und Nachschub ranzubringen. Das sehe ich auch als sagen mögliche Entwicklung äh in in nächster Zeit.
Ja ähm aber alle, aber die Szenarien äh sagen, dass es dann wieder wieder aufflammt äh und und noch mal eskaliert werden. Damit wären mit einem Waffenstillstand, glaube ich, auch noch nicht vom Tisch.
Gut, also ich denke,
Jetzt hätte ich fast gesagt, die nächsten Tage werden entscheidend sein. Keine Ahnung. Es könnte könnte könnte sein, könnte aber auch nicht äh sein, dass sich da irgendwas entscheide. Ich denke, hier ist generell äh alles noch noch drin im Topf.
So oder so was man glaube ich mal festhalten kann ist mit den Sanktionen.
Hat der Westen schon ein extrem scharfes Schwert geschwungen. Und in gewisser Hinsicht hat es sogar noch Eskalations.
Potenzial. Diese ganze Debatte um raus aus dem Gas, raus aus dem Öl.
Abgesehen davon, dass es schwierig sein wird, dass kurzfristig hinzubekommen, ist, glaube ich, jetzt die Entscheidung das langfristig hinzubekommen, sogar schon gefallen.
Müsste in Russland langsam klar werden, dass sie einfach in zehn Jahren.
Wenn sich da nicht ganz grundsätzlich was verändert in dem Laden, dass sie in zehn Jahren nicht nicht nicht einen Liter Gas mehr irgendwie durch ihre Pipeline gedrückt bekommen. Das ist so die Perspektive äh in in der sie stehen.
Nachgeschlagen, also auch Coca-Cola äh hat jetzt irgendwie kleinen Ball gegeben. Es ist einfach dieses Land verabschiedet sich vollständig.
Aus dieser westlich geprägten Weltwirtschaft und es gibt glaube ich kaum eine andere, auf die sie aufspringen könnten und das das wird sich zwangsläufig irgendwann verdichten. Ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen,
dass dass diese Deadline ähm wirklich erst im Juli Juni liegt wie dieser FSB-Bericht noch vermutet hat.
Allerdings.
Mein anderes Problem ist, dass wahrscheinlich man jetzt auch beginnen müsste so langsam äh in der Ukraine äh mit
aussaaten zu beginnen damit auch im Sommer und im Herbst äh irgendwie Dinge geerntet äh werden.
Guter Punkt, den haben wir noch gar nicht angesprochen.
So, ja
das heißt da ist gar nicht Zeit bis bis zum Sommer, wenn nicht in den wenn eigentlich wenn nicht in den nächsten weiß ich nicht vier Wochen
nicht irgendwie Ruhe einkehrt dann sehen wir tatsächlich auch 'ne globale Hungerkatastrophe äh
auf die Welt zukommen. Weniger jetzt, ich sage mal in den Reichen Ländern, aber die ganzen Schwellenländer und die Ärmeren
äh äh Länder äh werden natürlich extrem in mit Leidenschaft gezogen äh werden plus
ja ich habe das Gefühl, dass das mit jedem Tag auf einmal wo,
alle Leute auch drüber nachdenken, was passiert jetzt auch die Russen denken ja drüber nach. Das sollte man jetzt auch nicht nicht unterschätzen, dass äh sagen
auch Putin oder äh äh die Leute um ihn herum nicht
äh ständig jetzt nachdenken und äh auch überlegen, welche Optionen haben Sie jetzt und wie können Sie das jetzt anpassen und ich habe das Gefühl,
je
Mehr davon jetzt plötzlich allen vor Augen geführt wird oder je mehr man darüber nachdenkt, was da gerade Schlimmes passiert. Äh äh umso,
mehr äh könnte halt ein Umdenken einfach auch stattfinden in äh Russland. So weil wie gesagt ich glaube nicht, dass Putin verrückt
ist äh sondern äh ich denke, wenn er feststellt, dass er seine Ziele so nicht.
Erreichen können wird, dass er dann andere Mittel und Wege suchen wird oder auch auch umschwenken äh wird
und äh ja äh und dann also irgendwann werden wir an dem an dem Punkt auf jeden Fall ankommen, wo glaube ich beide Seiten,
Westen wie auch die Russen sehen werden. Oh mein Gott äh das wird uns jetzt hier alles äh zu schlimm.
Ja also ich denke an der Stelle belassen wir das jetzt äh vielleicht auch erst mal, sonst wird das hier aber auch wieder alles viel zu lang.
Ähm gucken wir mal, was in den nächsten Tagen ähm passiert.
Auf jeden Fall leider immer noch eine ganze ist auf jeden Fall leider immer noch eine ganze Menge Musik drin hier in dieser Geschichte.
Gerade läuft auch sehe ich, sehe ich grade äh läuft auch eine Meldung, DAX steigt um acht Prozent.
Hoffnung im Ukrainekrieg, wachsende Chancen auf eine diplomatische Annäherung von Russland. Haben an den Börsen ein Kurzkurs-Feuerwerk ausgelöst. Interessant.
Oder wie gesagt aus meiner.
Habe ich auch gelesen, aber ich weiß nicht genau, wo sie den Optimismus jetzt so hernehmen, um ehrlich zu sein.
Ähm na ja ähm ich meine oft ist es so, dass die Leute, die dann an den Börsen
spekulieren die haben dann irgendwelche Oligarchen-Freunde oder so ähm
Und äh ja weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht ist es auch nur ein vielleicht ist es auch nur ein Gerücht
aber ähm ja man man wird sehen. Ich meine meine meine These ist äh dass das äh äh Russland jetzt äh einfach Zeit,
braucht, um äh ja, sich sich zu konsolidieren und ähm das wahrscheinlich
ja erstmal versuchen wird vielleicht schon ernsthafte Verhandlungen zu führen äh jetzt zum zum ersten Mal. Aber man man wird sehen, man wird sehen ob das zu was zu was führt gerade.
So Leute, damit äh belassen wir äh die Gedanken erst mal für diese Sendung und ähm lassen euch jetzt erst mal so in Gedanken äh zurück und wir werden in den nächsten Tagen hier sicherlich nochmal gucken, wie es weitergegangen ist.
Ja macht's gut. Tschüss.
Bis bald. Tschüss.